Hey... Why are you laughing?
No, when I say swap!
What?
What did I say?
Nothing!
I just said...
You've been like dealing with this for years now.
Why now do you laugh?
Why?
Nothing!
Hi guys!
Hey everybody!
So first off, I just want you guys to know we were selling technical difficulties for at least 30 minutes.
Oh my god, we were so prepared.
Yeah, we were so prepared guys.
It was just very unfortunate that the last five minutes that we had, like just something came up unexpectedly.
It was crazy.
Oh yeah, and it was on Min's side, not on mine.
No, wait, wait, wait.
I plead mac and cheese, you plead Germany.
Wait, what?
What about that?
Yeah, okay look.
The reason why I didn't start and Min started before me was because Dokkaebi, we had to connect to a special server to be there.
And I forgot I was connected to that special server.
So I was streaming over at Germany.
So someone out there was watching the starting screen in Germany and being like, where did this person come from?
It was like Grandpa Joe just trying to watch Jeopardy.
And he was like...
The worst part was the starting screen was not even playing.
It was just a still image.
So he must be freaking out right now and being like aliens or some shit.
Like, Martha!
The TV won't swap!
The TV!
Wait, how do you know?
How do you say that in German?
When do you think I know German?
Well, you were, okay, you were mis-invited to a German convention.
Look, I would say an European convention.
It is a convention for all of EU.
Europe is not just German mint.
Wow.
You gotta open your mind.
It was in Germany!
Yeah, you gotta open your mind and be more inclusive to the other countries in Europe.
Okay, name every country in Europe.
Alright.
European Union.
Who's not in the European Union?
Well, then they're not European and...
I'm joking!
Guys, that was a joke, guys.
That was a joke, everybody.
Wow, and now she's lumping everyone in Europe under the European Union.
Wow.
No one can have individuality here.
Oh yeah?
You name every country in Europe then.
I already asked you.
Yeah, but you're like, oh, you're ragging me on about my lack of European knowledge.
You think I know?
I don't know, then why are you ragging me?
I could have named random countries and you wouldn't know because you don't know Europe apparently.
Okay, name three countries and I'll tell you which one is real.
Oh, you're gonna play that?
Alright, give me a sec.
Oh no, she has to Google.
Give me a sec, alright.
I also have Google.
You gotta Google.
That's not knowing the answer if you're Googling.
I don't know.
Alright.
Oh, what are you Googling, huh?
What are you Googling?
I'm Googling...
Countries of the world.
No, I said nice things.
I Googled nice things to send to my mom.
Guys.
Wait a sec.
Oh, so you're not even prioritizing the stream.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm waiting on you, Toki.
You're the one holding us up.
Alright, alright, alright.
Fine, fine.
Okay.
Faso.
Why are you laughing?
Wait, what?
Peso?
Yeah, Faso.
Malawi.
Eritrea.
Which one's the fake?
Which one?
The third one?
Eritrea.
I would like to phone a friend.
You don't know either!
They were all real!
I'm so sorry!
They were all in Africa!
You said you know every country in the world.
So I gave you every country in the world.
I gave you specific... You don't know any African countries.
That's fucked up.
I know some.
I know Zanzibar.
I gave you three and you couldn't even tell which one was mine.
Which one was the real one?
But they were all real!
You said... You said Europe!
Yeah, you went with countries in the entire world.
So I was like, entire world, huh?
Okay, entire world!
Oh my god.
This is... This is slander.
Anyway, should we play the game?
Okay.
I'm over playing GeoGuessr.
Alright, we're playing GeoGuessr now.
You're right.
I should have selected South America country.
Oh yeah?
How many countries have you been to in South America?
Like... zero?
How about you, huh?
I think it's just a few minutes of America.
I've been to one!
Yeah?
Which one was it?
Argentina!
Oh yeah.
Yeah, but you were there for like one second.
Does that really count?
No!
I talked to the locals.
And they said, Papa Frita is so small.
That's all you got from it?
What's the fucking context?
I was eating really small fries from McDonald's at the airport.
So they were like making fun of you?
Yeah, they were.
She was like, I need to take a picture of this.
You're eating the small fries.
So I turned up mid a little bit, guys.
I turned her up.
So you guys can hear her better.
It's not like she's giving us any good input or anything, but at least you can hear her.
I'm gonna come over.
I'm gonna send you to Brazil.
We're gonna go to Brazil together.
We're gonna go to Brazil, guys!
Don't get mad at her coming to Brazil!
Brazil, my chick!
Alright.
Alright, are we ready?
So apparently we found out that we can actually potentially kill people in this game.
And like, if any of that actually happens...
Oh god.
Wait, so if like my characters die, do I just stop playing the game?
I think you just take over a different character.
Maybe?
Okay, maybe.
I don't know.
We'll find out.
I guess we'll see when you kill off your character.
Also, there's QuickTime events, by the way.
Do you know that?
Basically like until dawn.
Yeah, and then my chat was like, oh, Min and QuickTime events.
What the hell does that mean?
What's that supposed to mean?
I don't know.
I'm good with the QuickTime.
I wonder if I should play this with a controller.
Oh, because I am.
Oh, you are?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna grab my controller.
Yeah, I feel like this game is meant to be.
Until Dawn was meant to be played on a controller.
You're right.
Hold on.
Okay, I'm good.
Isn't this the creators of Until Dawn?
I'm pretty sure.
I think so.
Yeah, so it was meant to play.
Alright, you guys ready?
New slot.
I'm ready.
Oh, I want to be Joe or Charlie.
Guys, which one has a higher chance of living?
Joe, Joe Schmo, Joe Schmo.
Joe Schmo, Charlie Warley.
Charlie Warley.
Joey.
He believes in the heart of the cards.
Okay, oh, you're right.
I'm gonna be Joe.
I identify with Joey.
Just kidding.
Joey's a wimp.
I'm ready.
I'm ready, Charlie.
I handle your Charlie.
I'm Mint Phantom.
For now.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Wait.
To play with the controller, press A.
Okay.
Okay, that's cool.
That'd be funny if we're like, you can only play with one.
The other has to do M and K.
Oh my god.
That would be torture.
Man of Madon.
Madon?
What is it?
You don't know either.
It's like a Madan, right?
It is Madon.
Okay, to be fair, everybody knows I pronounce things wrong 99% of the time.
So maybe you're right.
That's gonna be you.
That's gonna be you in that box.
That's me.
Oh wait, in that box?
You're dead.
I know.
That's bad.
Oh!
Ooh!
Elvis Presley.
I bet like, oh my god.
Are we coming back from the war?
I guess so.
What war though?
There's a lot in America.
There are so many choices.
I don't know.
It doesn't give us a date.
Yeah.
But this is, you know this is based on like a real ship, right?
Wait, it is?
Wait, this is based off real life?
Yeah.
Yeah, they found a ship that like everybody died on.
Oh!
And they couldn't figure out why they all died.
Doki Bird is Joe!
That's right!
The director called me up to act on this movie game.
That's you, Charlie!
Well, I'm wasted.
Yeah, you're so drunk.
Oh no, Charlie.
There's no subtitles.
Oh yeah, you turn it on yourself.
I turn mine on.
Guys, I have subtitles.
Wait, how do I turn it on?
I guess we'll find... you'll have to find out after this scene.
Wisp!
I have subtitles.
Look at it, she's hot.
Oh my god, he's fighting that thing.
Kick his ass.
Oh wait, this is me!
Oh my god.
Punch!
What are you gonna do?
R to aim?
T to punch.
Punch?
Can I punch this thing?
Use R to choose... can I like move it for you?
Oh, I can!
You can?
Yeah!
Can you not move it?
Wait, I am moving it.
No, you're not.
I'm moving it.
No, I'm moving it.
This is totally me!
No, you're not?
Okay.
I wanna know, will I be rich?
Oh my god, me!
Wait, how do I pick?
How do I pick?
I'm killing it, I'm killing it, I'm killing it!
What are you doing?
I'm doing QTEs!
I'm QTEs!
Oh, we're doing different things!
Wait, why can't I pick?
Oh.
Why'd you buy the game?
Don't you have to...
Wait, yeah, you go do your fucking settings.
Yeah, hold on, I'm doing my subtitles.
Oh, you're actually doing it?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm doing my subtitles.
Okay, we're good.
Continue.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Four, three, two...
Now you threw off my groove.
Oh, wait, you're fighting?
Yes, I'm fighting!
Oh.
Wait, I can't press anything!
Wait!
It wasn't a pick!
You should've picked Charlie!
Okay.
Wait, I didn't turn you off anyway.
This gives me a chance to turn you off anyway.
Oh my god.
Okay.
How do I pick?
I'm continuing thinking.
Okay.
I'm pressing B!
Yeah, it's my QTEs!
What's R?
It's not letting me pick!
I swear, I'm pressing everything!
Yeah, because I'm the one who's playing!
No, I have my own screen!
I have my own...
I don't know what's going on in your side!
I'm playing now!
It's not letting me pick!
I'm pressing everything!
Can you help me in English?
You suck at the game!
I already beat it.
Oh, you're already done?
Okay guys, I didn't say anything.
Wait... were you playing like a game of cards?
I was trying to do the dialogue section, but I couldn't pick a dialogue.
I was gaming... and you were dying to some old man who's asleep.
Oh wait, now I have to do the thing you just did.
Oh, you were doing this.
Were you able to pick a tile?
You were doing this and you were freaking out?
I picked it.
What did you press?
You just move with R.
Yeah, but how did you select it?
Oh, I'm gonna use the rooster tile.
You just hover over it.
You just hover over it?
That's all you did?
That's literally it?
Yes, you're wrong too.
It wasn't just press R.
You just hover.
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
I don't know anything about my son.
What about my son?
I don't think you'll never know.
I'll never know.
I'll never know about my son.
Or if I'll ever be rich.
I'll never know.
I just did nothing.
I feel like it's hard to balance the audio in this.
He's told me like... blood.
Oh, are you done?
Yeah, I'm done.
You don't need to know anything more about your future.
If I don't know my future, you don't know your future.
Did you beat the dummy?
Yeah, I beat the dummy.
I did it faster than you.
Did you get hit?
No.
Did you get hit on the quick time events?
I don't believe you.
Did you get hit on the...
No, I did not.
Did you get hit on the quick time events?
If anybody's dying, it's on your side.
No, I got an achievement for it.
I got an achievement.
I think all of us get an achievement for finishing it.
Oh shit, the death box.
That's gonna be you.
I mean, judging by the quick time events stuff, I think it's you.
Don't write death, POV.
I might not make right dialogue.
See, we got our strengths.
I'm the quick time event person and you're the dialogue person.
Wait, why are there three boxes of death?
Wait, who's the third person?
Uh oh, it's chat.
It's chat.
Wait, one of our chats survives.
Uh oh.
Oh, who's that guy?
Hey man.
Where's my 50 cents?
What?
50 cents.
Yeah, I was like, what 50 cents?
Come on man.
Man, you don't need 50 cents.
You stole my 50 cents.
Whoa!
That's the third guy.
No, that was you.
You just got punched by a dude.
Audio
is like so...
Why is it so loud?
Yeah, I know.
Why is the sound effect so loud?
Why are you dead already?
Come on.
I'm dead.
Like, what did I do?
You're the drunk one.
Like, hold it.
You are too.
You got punched in the face.
You're the one who punished me for fucking 50 cents and then I got punched?
Like...
Guys, it's not the game voice that's low.
It's the...
It's everything else is high.
Yeah, I think that.
Yeah.
I keep trying to like adjust it but it's like all over the place.
Okay.
Uh oh.
Oh, there's the ship.
Whoa!
Oh, no.
What the fuck?
Titanic moment.
It struck...
Oh.
Ew!
What is that?
That's some goo.
The death is leaking into the water.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Frankenstein.
The new pandemic.
Did you guys know that Frankenstein... the reason his arms are stuck out is because he was supposed to be blind and they just wrote that out of the story but kept his arms sticking out.
So...
It's gotta mess up.
It's Frankenstein's monster.
Whatever.
If you're gonna give a fact about Frankenstein, use the correct terminology.
Frankenstein's monster.
What the fuck?
Whoa!
What's going on?
Oh, I'm in the rig.
Mint is Charlie.
There's you.
Where is Joe?
Oh, wait.
That's me.
Yeah, you're looking at yourself.
Oh, yeah.
I'm looking at myself.
Wait, where are you?
I'm at the sickbay.
Okay, I paused it because I need it.
Why'd you pause?
Because I didn't just see audio!
The audio is fucked up!
You're right.
I'm putting the sound effects and the music down.
We do not need such high sound effects.
No, I'm gonna put it like 70.
I'm gonna put it at 72.
Yeah.
See?
You're welcome.
I'm gonna put it at 72.
What's an audio preset?
I have no idea.
I just put...
Oh, nevermind.
I turned down music and the sound effects.
Are you ready?
Hold on.
Alright, fine.
You can put...
You press continue then.
Oh, I'm pressing continue.
Oh.
I'm pressing continue.
There we go.
Three.
Two.
One.
I guess people can use the settings thing to fuck each other over.
Oh, there's blood on the wall.
Wait.
There's blood on...
Oh, wait.
I got the med kit.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Okay.
It's not my blood.
Call an ambulance but not for real.
Okay.
I know where the blood came from.
Oh, wait.
I need to move me in my chat.
There's text that's on the right side.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, I know where the blood came from.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
I'm moving us over.
Chat, come over here, chat.
That's not a bad kid.
Chat, come here.
Oh, you guys are like censored to...
Oh, gosh.
You guys, don't worry about it.
Okay, sorry.
Five, four, three, two...
What?
Why?
So, there's a dead body on my side.
There's just blood on the wall here.
Let's see.
Oh, I'm looking at a key.
Oh!
Whoa!
What a key.
I have a key.
I'm just looking at blood.
Who is this?
Come get me out of here then, maybe.
Maybe that's for me to get out.
I need to see... wait, it's a doctor.
Is he dead?
Yes, I'm pretty sure he was stuffed in the locker.
I'm pretty sure he's dead.
Private Charles...
What happened?
Wait, what happened while I was sleeping?
While we were both sleeping?
Ooh, that's me.
Yeah, what the heck happened?
To Pops, come back soon.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure we weren't sleeping for that long.
Do you have a safe code?
I'm opening up a lock.
I'm coming out.
I'm coming out of the ship.
Out of the ship?
Where are you?
I'm outside the ship now.
Okay, I don't like how...
You don't know what's going on.
I'm stuck in the brig.
Oh my gosh, this is tank... oh, it's Resident Evil.
The brig?
Something's gonna pop out at me.
Oh...
Wait, is that you?
Are you in this side?
Well, yeah, that's me.
That's you, Charlie.
Just get me out of here already.
Oh, you were in detention for punching me.
You were in detention.
I didn't punch you.
Oh, yeah?
Why were you locked inside?
I don't know...
Something's wrong.
Let's get out of here.
What are you looking at?
What is happening?
Find out what's happening on this ship.
Where are we gonna go?
Where are we gonna go, Charlie?
Charlie, where are we gonna go, Charlie?
This way?
I don't know.
Don't you know where we are?
Stuck in the wall.
You're stuck in the wall.
This way, this way!
Oh, go, Jory!
What's that?
I don't know!
Run!
That's gonna be you.
What's that?
Press A in time with a harpy?
Okay.
If you don't get this right, I swear to God.
We fucked up!
You fucked up!
You fucked me!
We were fine!
Where do we come from?
Where do we go?
Oh, wait, this is where we came from.
We just were like, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Two bumbling guys, Charlie and Joe.
Charlie and Joe, the adventures of Charlie and Joe.
What is this?
How did you mess up that?
You just pressed A!
I wanted to see what would happen if he caught us.
Oh, yeah, yeah, you wanted to see what would happen.
He didn't shoot us, it's fine.
He was safe, he was safe.
Okay.
What the hell?
Okay, I'm gonna put settings up right now.
Okay, get ready.
I need to turn you up again.
Okay.
Settings time.
Yeah, yeah, I need it.
Okay, we both need to fix it, so that's fine.
Okay, I turned my sound effects to 60.
Why is the sound effects so loud?
I don't know.
Actually, I'm gonna turn mine down a little bit too.
Yeah, okay, I'm gonna turn you up a little bit.
And I'm turning the overall game a little bit.
Alright.
This should work.
Is this A Way Out or whatever that game is?
Well, it feels like it.
It's like the horror version of A Way Out.
Sorry, chat, you're cut off a little bit.
Let me...
Alright, here, I'm ready.
Are you ready?
Yeah, I already clicked ready.
Okay, I don't know that.
I can't see.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
We're walking down the hall.
We're fine.
Wait, where did you go?
Oh, there you are.
Didn't we come here?
Who's that?
Who's that, Joe?
Did you not see it?
Charlie, did you not see it?
Charlie, did you not see the guy running in front of us?
No, there was no guy.
Wait, oh no, what's going on?
What are you talking about?
Charlie, I think I'm still drunk.
Joe, take your meds.
I caught it.
The doctor's dead.
There's a door flashing over there.
Yeah, yeah, over here.
Why are our feet smelly?
Ew.
Wait, did you not see it?
There's like a...
flashing over here.
I'm getting it.
Come on, Joe.
Help me.
I literally just came back from the sickbay.
Why is my face just so...
Alright, oh.
A!
I'm pressing A repeatedly!
I'm pressing A.
Yeah, he's dead.
Yeah, you said it.
Fubar and then some.
What the fuck?
What does that even mean?
What does that mean?
Oh my god.
Oh, that's a lot of blood.
Are we getting invaded?
What's happening?
What happened on the ship?
Stays on the ship.
Oh, okay.
I'm first, I guess.
Even though I opened the door?
Our feet are really smelly.
Wait, why is there like gas on the floor?
That's what I'm saying!
We're smelly.
Another step.
Who's the lucky winner?
I'm checking him out.
I'm trying to check him out.
What do you see?
I'm stuck.
Oh, there it is.
What's going on?
He looks like Peter Griffin.
I wanna see too.
The bomb!
Oh my god, it's him!
He's not one of us.
Wait, what's wrong with his eyes?
He's like looking... he's like blank eyes.
Yeah.
What's going on, guys?
I feel like those like...
Like the frat boys be like...
Hey guys, what's going on?
What do we do?
Wow, look at these camera angles.
So cinematic.
Oh, did you went through that door?
I can't see anything.
Where are you?
I'm heading downstairs.
Oh my god, it is so cinematic.
I can't see where I'm going.
Oh, FUBAR is a military snack for fucked unbelievably beyond all recognition.
Woah!
Oh my god!
To walk faster.
Okay, yeah, I like that.
Okay.
Alright, now we can... can we run?
I don't feel like I'm walking very much.
Me too.
I feel like...
I don't think I'm walking that fast.
Not gonna lie.
Me neither.
Are we... maybe we're not pressing the right button.
It's LB.
What are you...
I don't know.
There's one button.
Maybe it's wrong.
Which one is me?
Oh, this is me.
Woah!
Did you not see that?
No, I didn't see anything.
Oh, it's only me!
It was a child.
No.
Jo, what's wrong with you?
Of course you, Doki, would be the one.
The crazy one.
You would be the one.
You're so crazy.
So you're walking in circles.
You're just like, I don't know.
I don't know, Charlie.
I don't feel so good.
I don't feel so good, Charlie.
I'm seeing children.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Cow, cow, cow!
Uh oh.
I have a gun.
Is that a good idea?
Wait.
Why did I get a knife?
What the hell?
Why can't I ever have a gun?
You know why.
This is accurate.
This is very accurate.
Oh my god.
You were meant to have the katana.
I was meant to have the gun.
The katana.
Was that meme the guy...
I don't think you... You were having hallucinations.
I don't think you should be holding anything.
Is that you?
That's me.
I saw another child.
I saw a child again.
Yeah.
What the fuck do you see on your screen?
Oh!
The dead people are actually talking to me right now.
Oh, okay.
So at least we're not all...
We're both crazy then.
Oh!
What?
What just happened?
Oh god, no.
It's you talking to me.
Wait, what?
Yeah, you're looking at me.
But you're dead.
Uh, I'm gonna investigate.
Wait, how do I investigate?
How are you investigating?
I'm still hallucinating.
Um, I'm investigating your body.
Oh, there's a... There's a man here!
Wait, there's me!
No, I think you're the man.
Wait, what?
No, child!
I see the...
The child has your knife!
You gave the child the knife!
No, I still have it!
I still have it!
No!
I shot the child!
Oh my god!
I missed!
I saw a bit.
You missed?
You missed!
Are you shooting me?
I don't know, but I missed apparently.
Wait, did I die from that?
I think I'm dead too.
What?
What the...
Oh my god!
This guy used the force on me and killed me.
I tried...
I missed the child and then I died from a heart attack.
I just died from a...
You died from cringe because you were so bad.
You died from cringe, real.
Who is he?
That's not Charlie or Joe.
Give us your location.
Do it!
Do it, man!
You're our only hope!
Random sailor!
Uh oh.
Wait, what?
What the hell?
He has four arms!
Doki, I think something weird is going on here.
Yeah, I think this ship might be haunted.
He's got his little baby cross.
God cannot save you now!
Wait, what?
Woah!
Oh, he's...
He's dead!
Oh my god, he's dead!
Oh my god, he died of cringe too!
Everybody's dying of cringe!
Oh my god, it's so loud.
I cannot...
I like how they were like, picked between Joe and Charlie and they're already dead.
Yeah, that was the prologue!
We get the whole...
We get the game now.
Woah, woah, woah.
This isn't a ship.
We're at a mansion now.
Yay!
Do they still make these games?
I don't know.
I know they're doing really bad right now.
You know what?
I saw the reviews for it.
The newer episodes were not doing so well.
Uh oh.
Oh, who's this guy?
Isn't he the guy that was the...
Oh, is he?
I don't know.
He could be.
I think so.
Oh, apparently we're gonna get a copyright strike because of this song.
Oh!
I'm turning it down.
Oh, you're turning it down?
It's okay, they're just gonna get our ad money.
That's alright.
Oh, yeah.
Look at the... the ring girl.
What is going on?
Like, where did she go?
Why is she there?
Is this like some paranormal activity?
I like...
Is this like the video game version of the Annabelle chip?
And the nun?
What were they called?
They had names.
They were like the couple that investigated paranormal activities.
Yeah, yeah.
Anne and Lorraine Warren or whatever.
What was the name of those movies called?
Wasn't it just Annabelle, right?
No, they had a name.
It was a series.
Oh, okay.
The Conjuring!
The Conjuring, yeah!
That's us!
We're the Conjuring!
We're the Conjurers!
Joe and Charlie.
Who died.
He's walking down his own hallway so dramatically.
Yeah.
Oh, now he's lighting candles.
Hello.
Is this the sound one?
Yeah, thank you.
Okay.
His suppository?
Is that the things you stick up your ass?
I think so.
If you're wondering why I know this, guys, it's because I watch a lot of doctor shows.
Yeah, that's the only reason she knows.
That's the only reason I know.
Then why do you know it, huh?
The curator of stories.
You're not answering the question, man.
Wait, what did you say?
Why do you know what suppository is?
Oh, because I watch the shows with you.
Oh, true.
Oh, yeah.
You were there.
Yeah.
He's breaking the fourth wall.
He's talking to us.
Yeah.
Ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
No, I'm falling down.
Snuffed out.
Yeah.
You see, we each make decisions according to our own moral compass.
I think I have a great moral compass.
You literally couldn't press A.
Ha ha ha ha.
It was a lot of pressure.
Ha ha ha.
It is the tax one pays for how we live.
And it comes eventually to everybody.
Eventually.
Still, none of us want for it to come too soon.
Yeah, Mint.
Ha ha ha.
Hey, hey, hey.
I'm already dead.
I fear nothing.
Sometimes separately.
What one does may not make complete sense to the other because we all have different perspectives.
Yeah, anything you do makes no sense to me.
Ha ha ha.
And neither does you.
That's why it's perfect.
We're playing this.
Yeah, it's perfect.
I think the goal is to at least have one person survive.
Probably.
Who will it be?
You or me?
Ha ha ha.
Here's one for free.
Oh.
There are pictures in this world that can show you some possible future.
Oh, so it's like a hint.
Yeah.
They may just help you to make better decisions.
Oh no.
I think that's subjective.
If they're better or not.
Yeah, like how do we know if they're better decisions?
Yeah.
That's all for the moment.
We'll talk again soon enough.
We'll have the opportunity to account for all the actions that you've taken.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Do we need to pay you now?
Or like...
I don't know this guy.
Is this a trial period?
Oh, that's where we were.
That's the opening screen.
It was just the water.
Ooh.
Doki Bird is Alex.
You're Brad?
I'm Brad.
You're Brad.
I'm probably really cool.
Which one is this?
Cool name, you know.
Is this the Brad or the Alex?
Oh, I look like a nerd.
I'm your brother.
We're brothers.
Brad's brother.
How do we always end up being brothers?
Wait, which one?
Is that you?
Are you the nerd?
Yes.
Look at this nerd.
Oh my god.
Winnie.
You're insecure.
Brad's brother.
Why does yours say innocent?
What does that imply about me?
I'm an innocent maiden.
Down.
Diving.
Maybe you could show me how the pros do it.
Ooh.
Doki Bird is deciding.
Let's see.
You didn't take lessons?
I'm not going to take lessons.
Kind of.
Yeah.
You think I can just save you like that?
I'm going to say nothing.
That's right.
Know your place, nerd.
That cam is like super expensive.
Oh yeah.
Be cool.
What?
I'm an influencer.
You're an influencer?
Maybe.
I don't know.
I have a camera.
So don't sweat the little stuff, man.
It's not cool.
Don't make me regret letting you tag along.
Yeah.
Don't make me regret it.
Now you're deciding again.
You know I'm not like the best around new people.
Oh, you're anxious.
We're excited, Winnie.
We're buddies.
Oh, wait.
I can see your traits.
Oh, that's what you're looking at.
What was it?
RB?
Yeah, RB.
Wait, we have secrets too.
I can't see it since I'm in the closet.
Oh my god.
I'm guarded, genuine.
I'm genuine, insecure, generous.
Never mind.
Who the fuck is Conrad and Fliss?
We're not there yet.
We have other people.
Alex reminded Brad he's not just a tag-a-log.
Alex was annoyed that Brad had not taken diving lessons.
Oh my god.
Come on, John.
I can't even see them.
Now I'm gonna see it.
Now you're gonna see it.
It's RB.
It's collections and characters.
That's what it was.
I'm witty.
I'm eager.
I'm innocent.
Yeah, but are you genuine like me?
You're not genuine.
My body is genuine.
It literally says genuine.
If you're not genuine...
Oh, you can't see it.
We can only see ourselves.
Mine says guarded, generous.
Genuine.
Yeah, I'm...
I mean, I let you come over to the diving...
to the diving place.
I could let you drown if I wanted to.
You're my bro.
You're my brother.
See?
I'm being supportive.
We're buddies.
I'm here to fucking hang.
Cool out and kick it.
Yeah, you gotta loosen up, bro.
Let's just kick it and be legends, man.
You're Apex Legends.
Sorry I'm a little snappy.
I'm just...
When you're in medical school, it'd be stressful.
What's wrong?
I'm in medical school right now?
Oh my god.
At least I'm a cool nerd.
You're a fucking influencer.
It's been like two weeks.
Come on, man.
Right on cue.
I'm smart and cool.
What are you?
I'm innocent.
I'm not gonna be a doctor.
I'm gonna save lives.
You need to save your own first.
Can I get your input on something?
Oh my god, I'm gonna propose.
Oh, you are?
Not a big thing I'm trying to make a decision about.
Yeah?
No, but...
It's just kind of a big life choice, you know?
Okay.
I don't know what's the right thing to do.
Oh my god, do I marry her or not?
I'm gonna...
say nothing.
Wow, you're so supportive.
Oh my god, that's my girlfriend!
Julia!
That's her brother!
He's relaxed.
He's a fool.
Oh, yo, you want me to hook you up with her brother?
Oh, wow.
You like that?
This is Alex.
Hey, what's up man?
Conrad.
Yeah.
Lady killer, right here.
What?
That's me.
He's ignoring you.
This Conrad guy looks like...
He looks like that actor.
Doctor Horrible.
Dr. Neopatric Harris?
Yeah, Neopatric Harris.
Do you miss me?
Of course.
I'm cracking a cold one!
Every second.
I love you.
I'm gonna be cool.
I'm gonna be cool, you guys.
No!
She called me needy!
I'm not needy, I swear!
I think this is my first time having a beer.
Are you cracking a beer?
Yeah, I'm having a cold one.
Oh, wait.
I thought I was throwing up.
I can't believe it.
Wait, who's that?
Who's this?
This is my love interest now.
Where's the old crusty?
Captain of the Duke of Milan.
Oh, dang.
Oh, shit.
Badass.
Oh my gosh, did you see her tattoo?
Yeah.
I'd invite you to make yourselves at home, but...
Uh...
Why is everyone...
Yeah.
Isn't she the captain?
You don't know who's sailing the ship.
Here we go.
You're selling, I'm buying.
Whoa!
Yeah, me too.
Conrad, that's fucked up.
Do not flirt with the person who knows how to drink.
You gotta drive the boat.
Yeah.
What are we doing here anyway?
We're diving?
Is that it?
Yeah, we're learning how to dive.
Cool.
The Duke of Milan.
Oh.
That's you.
No, that's you.
You're that in the blue shirt.
Oh, you're right.
What a fucking dude.
Look, she's like...
Comforting, man.
She likes it when they're weak.
Oh.
What about over here?
What is this?
That's pretty far out of the way.
Oh my gosh, going through the picks.
Can you see me going through the picks?
No, I'm fucking talking to the captain right now.
I'm looking at some...
Oh!
I found a ship.
Yeah.
This is different.
Dog?
Come here.
I think it's hot diggity dog.
Wait, you did your homework?
What do you mean?
Oh.
Yeah, we got a wreck.
We got a wreck.
We have to do some diving that you suggested.
The captain said it's not a good idea, but I trusted you, Mint.
I trusted your call.
Cool.
If we die, it's on you.
Oh, I'm looking at the pictures now.
Yeah.
I don't know, the captain was like, not a good idea.
Oh, wow!
Wow!
Mmmmm, nooooooo!
I'm gonna be disappointed.
Oh, why am I Conrad?
Wait, you're Conrad now?
Mint?
Mint,
what decision did you make?
Not because she's beautiful.
I mean, she is beautiful.
But that's like, a coincidence.
Oh my god.
Hey, I'm Conrad now, I have to do what I have to do.
I think I'm gonna marry a bitch.
She's like a Karen for real.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna marry a Karen.
Mint, why did you not say anything?
Why did you say nothing when I asked you?
You guys in the water enough to...
I'll set up the tanks.
The boys will do the final check.
It's not my call!
Take a look at the camera.
See if you can find anything.
That one second loading screen there.
Yeah, what the hell is that?
Maybe you should check on your bro?
Yeah, where's my... where's the bro?
Where's Brad?
Oh shi- oh.
Brad, where are you?
Where are you, Brad?
Oh my god.
Oh, look at the binoculars.
The way you like, walk and glide around.
Oooh.
I'll find you later.
I'm looking at the binoculars.
I'm looking at the pictures again.
I like the pictures.
I'm an iPad kid.
Ooh, that opening.
Okay, we got it.
Okay.
This is like such a tiny ship.
Where could Brad go?
I think he's laying down.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh, wait, where am I?
Wait.
Hey, I'm gonna talk to my girlfriend.
Me too.
You're a good girl.
You're like...
You're vibrating in this moment.
You need a hand.
I'm in this conversation too.
Let me in.
I think we're in good shape.
It's probably not a bad idea for you to have a few...
I'm actually in the conversation.
Hey, hey, J.J.
You all right?
J.J.
I'm sorry.
Got to say, not too happy with our captain at the moment.
She's right there.
Wait, what?
Who are you deciding?
I'm gonna be annoyed.
Oh, you're gonna be white knight her?
We paid top dollar to come out here in the middle of nowhere to do whatever the hell we want without any namby-pamby to keep her in the dark.
I know, me too.
Oh my god!
He's self-aware!
He's actually self-aware!
Why are you vibrating?
I'm trying to go to Brad!
I want to talk to him!
I want to look at the weather!
I'm going to Brad.
Oh, I turned it off.
Wait, I think I see a picture.
Is this one of those sneaky pictures?
Well, hello.
What's this?
What are you looking at?
I'm heading over.
I unlocked a premonition.
Oh, that's going to help me out with decisions, remember?
Yeah!
I want to see so I know that you won't fuck up.
He's going to be in here.
What's this premonition?
Wait, that's Brad.
Yeah, I don't...
It doesn't do anything.
What does that mean?
I'm trying to make a decision!
I'm trying to look at a premonition right now!
I'm making a decision!
Okay.
Brad's in the bathroom.
I'm going to be a dick to him.
You're going to be a dick to my bro?
You're going to be a dick to yourself?
I hate myself.
.
Why did he do that?
What's this?
Oh, there's cologne.
Captain Kiss?
I'm looking at cologne while you're bullying yourself.
Where are you?
Are you in the bathroom?
I was opening the closet.
There's another room here.
Oh, I'm going in.
Yeah, now I'll talk to my little bro.
What's up?
How you doing?
Sorry, that brewski got the better of me.
Hello, locker.
Oh, I'm going through people's things.
That's really normal.
All part of the adventure.
Oh, I'm looking at the cologne too.
Sorry for putting a damper on things.
No worries, dude.
Do more than that just to script the trip.
Why am I going through your stuff?
What the hell?
Look, I comfort my bro after you bullied him.
Why are you looking at my stuff?
Hey, hey, hey, I was just snooping.
What are you doing?
All this stuff was up to code.
I'm just being normal.
Yeah, you were looking at my cologne.
I saw you looking at my cologne.
I took your cologne, actually.
Wait, you took my cologne?
Oh, this...
Yeah.
I think we talked to our bro.
Now what do we do?
I'm gonna go talk to the captain now.
I'm gonna watch you talk to the captain.
I'm gonna watch you fail.
Yeah.
Hey, girl.
Really?
Get out of my cutscene.
Oh, captain by captain?
I like it when you're strong.
Sometimes I just wanna be kept in line.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't mind a little submission now.
Oh my god.
Turn one off.
That thing where you have to hit on me like every two seconds.
I think she likes it.
Bro.
So, is it working?
Where are you?
Come back to my cutscene.
These rules are all pretty basic stuff.
How much experience do you have with these kind of dives?
Are you still talking to me?
Yeah.
Pretty much an authority back home.
Oh yeah.
If you move around does he move?
Why don't you wanna follow the rules for unreported wrecks?
But all you know this could be a war.
Did you see me?
Yes.
I'm gonna be playful.
Bro, you're still talking to me.
I'm talking to her.
Holy shit.
You've never spoken to a woman before.
You've only talked to your sister.
Damn.
It's my turn to talk to her now.
Alright, you talk to her.
You talk to her.
I'm watching.
Are you talking to her?
No, I'm stuck.
Wait, the conversation.
Wait, I'm stuck.
Wait, I went inside.
Oh no.
I can't progress anything.
No.
Did you see me just looking around?
What's going on?
No.
We broke the game.
Fix it.
Talk to our sister.
Wait, wait, wait.
There you go.
No, I can't move.
I'm just stuck here.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go look at it.
Start the next scene, Min.
Start the next scene.
She said something.
What's going on?
I'm looking at her driver's license.
I'm such a freak.
How do we start the next scene?
Hold on.
I just doubted her credentials.
Wait, she's your sister.
What do you mean you doubted her credentials?
No, no, no.
Oh my god.
You're still standing there.
How do we start the game?
I can't.
I'm gonna push you.
Push me into the boat.
I can't push you.
I'm gonna go talk to my sister.
Oh my god.
We fixed it.
Perfect!
It gets totally reused.
Okay.
Oh yeah, yeah.
We have to do...
We won't die here.
I don't think I'm diving.
Are you gonna be my girlfriend now?
You gotta check your O2 first.
Oh, maybe.
Oh, okay.
Thanks for your playful.
I'm gonna be playful.
Bro, you were...
What the hell?
You were like creeping on the captain earlier.
I bought this drone.
This is the line.
Kabooey?
Oh my god, we are alone!
Right after defending you, Sissy!
You're like, anyway, I'm gonna hit him up with the captain again.
Wait, what's the baton stick?
Or the camera?
We don't need a camera.
We're gonna need that baton.
I don't know what this is.
A bang stick?
Take the camera or Julia?
Why is the lighting really dark all of a sudden?
I can't even know what's happening!
Why is the lighting so dark?
Oh, it's fixed.
It's fixed.
Oh my god.
What's happening?
I don't know.
Why is she just looking at us like that?
She's nervous.
I got a bang stick.
I got a stick that bangs.
Julia liked it last night.
Wait, so am I doing nothing?
Nice.
Alright, it's up to you, Dokie.
Wait a minute.
You were Brad, now Conrad, and now Julia?
Like, pick a lane.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
There's dead bodies in here.
Wait, there's dead bodies in here.
Is this Madon?
No, this is a plane.
It's a plane?
Yeah.
Why are we going in here?
Because we found this wreck.
Here we go.
Down we go.
Why are we diving when it's the sun setting?
Should we just wait for day?
Howdy, Captain.
You fancy climbing?
Are you still talking to her?
No, I'm watching the cutscene.
Uh oh.
You're gonna need to use your bang stick.
The boat looks really far away.
Wait, I'm gonna be fli- Okay.
Alright, you know what?
Sure.
I'll give you one.
Wait, are you on the boat?
Yeah, I'm Fliss.
I'm underwater.
You're hanging to be underwater.
No way!
You're the Karen.
We know why somebody died.
It's a long story.
Oh my god.
It's complicated and it's really difficult to explain.
Well, I'm a complicated guy.
Doki Bird is Fliss.
Why am I?
Why am I Julia?
All of a sudden- You're the Karen.
Oh my god.
You know you're smarter than you look.
If you're interested.
Here I go.
I'm going inside the ship.
Oh my god.
Comrade's like- Comrade wants to invest in my business.
What?
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
I want Conrad's money.
Oh, I almost just killed Julia, I think.
I suppose you could have that conversation.
Oh my god.
That scared me.
I just noticed something was wrong.
You know what?
I better spend some time keeping the Duke of Milan ship-shaped.
Explore the- the plane wreck.
Bye bye.
Let's see.
Wait for the others to return from the dive.
Oh, you are doing- Why are you doing the action?
I don't know!
Why am I doing the action part?
I'm just chilling.
I'm just chilling on the ship right now.
Why are we both- Oh, wait.
What was that?
Oh, I can talk to you.
You can?
Yeah.
Hello.
Duke to Alex.
Duke to Julia.
I didn't hear- Do you guys hear me?
Oh, I heard it.
I heard it.
We're looking at a hole.
Don't- ignore her.
Ignore Fliss.
You're gonna ignore me?
She's angry.
I'm gonna call you guys again.
I'm gonna- You think you can- I'm not even- You think you can just ignore me like that?
Duke to Alex.
Ring, ring, ring.
Duke to Julia.
Oh, you're gonna ghost me now?
Yeah, I'm doing risky business, okay?
Don't be such a gonad, doge god.
You think I'm not gonna spam call you now?
Don't you- Oh my god.
I think she might die.
Don't worry.
I'm calling you guys again.
Don't- Alex.
Duke to Julia.
Oh, there's an octopus in here!
Don't be such a gonad.
Okay, if you guys die, it's not on me.
You guys die.
I got it.
Okay, let's see.
What's this?
Oh, those are the photos.
Uh oh.
I'm lost.
Oh, he's here.
You're a good boyfriend.
He gave me oxygen.
Oh, nice.
Now you're gonna kill fucking Alex.
You're gonna kill Alex.
I spent so much- I spent a lot of difficult decisions to get Alex to where he's at and now you're just gonna kill him off.
I don't know what I'm doing.
She is so rude.
I told you.
She's such a Karen.
I hope she dies.
This- this- oh.
You found a secret.
Yeah.
Yeah, because I did risky business.
I told you.
Oh, I'm lagging.
Oh my god.
What's happening?
Okay.
Go easy on the booze.
I'm gonna- I'm bullying Brad right now.
See?
It's easy to bully him.
Well, let's avoid that tube.
What do you know, Brad?
He doesn't know anything.
It's Brad.
He's got a lot of bad theories.
I got tired of the speculation and wanted to see if there was actually anything there.
Okay.
Oh, the ship is around World War II.
Yeah, right?
Cause, uh...
How did you figure it out?
Everyone was just looking at where the plane was headed.
But, I asked myself, where is the plane from?
I'm using my bang stick.
What am I banging?
You're welcome.
I got you that bang stick.
I did it.
I used it.
Did she like it?
Oh my god!
It's a dead man.
She's banging?
I'm banging.
I'm investigating the ghost.
What?
What happened?
What the fuck?
An eel attacked me!
All I get is the ship with fucking Conrad.
You get to explore.
I had to deal with fucking Conrad.
Is that fair?
I'm just saying.
Maybe you should have picked Brad instead.
There's another guy.
Wait, let me investigate him, please.
Investigate.
I'm trying to turn around.
So, are you beached?
I'm piloting the plane?
Oh my god.
Should I hit on Conrad?
Yeah!
Do I do it?
I'm gonna hit on Conrad.
Do it.
Oh my god.
Conrad said he'll invest in my business.
You're in.
I'm in.
Oh my god.
My business is gonna flourish now.
I like how the girl was just like, it's not like we're gonna ruin the ship or anything.
And here I go, like ruining the ship.
Yeah.
I like how I'm also being your wingman right now.
Oh, he's holding something.
His wife and kids.
Oh my god.
He's in.
How do I turn this on?
Weather looks clear.
Am I just waiting on you guys to return to the ship?
Like what am I doing here?
I think so.
I'm just literally waiting.
Guys, hurry up!
Didn't what's his name say that like wrecking, like diving was his thing?
Oh there's pirates!
What?
Uh oh, what do you mean there's pirates?
Like yo ho.
That's not the coast guard.
Uh oh.
Wait, what do you mean?
So we're not under arrest.
Mint, I think... I'm stuck.
I think...
Do I need to come back?
You should call me back.
I think there's pirates.
You should call and say like hey.
Get up here.
You got that?
Oh no.
Oh, oh what's going on?
There's pirates.
I fucked up.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
They're moving the ship!
They're moving the plane!
Oh my god they're destroying it!
Wait, what?
They're destroying the plane.
Grab that.
Who's they?
Oh my god there's a shark!
I don't know.
Something...
We got damage here, you see this?
Something pulled him.
Come at me shark!
What do you think?
Like, uh...
10 bucks cover it?
Wow, you guys are doctor and also a marine biologist.
How does he know everything?
Okay, Mint.
We're coming back.
Um, comrade's a bitch.
He's antagonizing the pirates.
Mint, he's just like...
What?
Let's go.
I think Alex is trying to propose under here.
In the...
In the water!
He's trying to propose!
Um...
Oh my god.
I don't know what to say.
I'm just gonna say nothing.
What's going on?
You got a funny way of saying thank you, Conrad.
Oh, he gave up.
Okay.
Um, seriously?
What's going on?
What's going on, Alex?
What is going on, dad?
There are so many things going on.
I know.
When you think of something, I'll just be over here, taking the view...
My relationship with Alex is going down.
My relationship with Conrad is also going down.
It's nice to know we're both sabotaging each other's relationships.
I know.
It's fine.
I can make it up.
I make it up in tenfold.
Whatever you say to her doesn't mean anything.
Oh my god, Conrad's fucking... Oh!
Conrad's barbecuing.
And he's fucked up.
I'm more like you.
What do you mean?
I'm controlling the captain!
I didn't even get to make a choice.
I'm going.
He's like, we gotta decompress.
She's heroic.
Oh, and Alex is just chilling in the water.
Wait, I'm stuck on... okay.
Alright, Conrad, it's going down.
Guys, I'm messing up Conrad after all the hard work I did flirting.
Hey, JJ, don't worry about it.
What's going on?
Why did they go at sunset?
You see that money in the...
Yeah, what's that?
What's that money?
It was a little, uh, mishap.
With the barbecue.
I'm all true-stick now.
The whole boat was lit up.
Yeah, for real.
It was Conrad's fault.
So, why are you paying the ocean?
Yeah, why are you paying the ocean?
A fishing boat came by and got damaged on the dive line.
Oh, that's what happened.
They were being a little surly about it, so Conrad made it rain and they pissed off.
Wow.
Whatever.
They didn't even take the money.
What I wanna know is what you guys find.
Yeah, what did you find?
We found the plane.
And it is huge.
Full of cool stuff.
Yeah, like eels and sharks apparently.
Yeah.
What?
Why?
The dive line, actually.
Yeah, the dive line.
How bad?
Uh, there's no cockpit anymore for starters.
Well, that's just fucking perfect.
Well, that's not our fault.
Like, we didn't do that.
You're the captain of the ship.
Well, how is it my fault?
Yeah.
Conrad fucking threw money on the ship.
Oh, hey, did we do okay?
Yeah, how did we do, man?
How did we do?
He's laughing at us.
You're getting to know these intrepid adventurers then.
Yeah.
Alex and his little brother Brad.
Are we doing okay?
Trying to swim with the big fish.
Both seem out of their depth.
Yeah.
And Julia.
Julia.
Oh, of Alex's life.
I don't know.
After what Mint did, I don't know anymore.
I don't know about that.
It's not one diving trip that's gonna destroy their relationship.
Captain Fliss.
Strong.
Forthright.
Stubborn.
Do I detect a spark between her and Conrad?
We're gonna force them to like each other.
Wait, we have a special feature unlocked.
That's a special feature.
And some I think they may regret.
His jacket looks like a...
giraffe.
Like a cantaloupe skin.
Apparently we made some decisions that they're gonna regret later.
Nooo.
I mean they'll regret.
I think you made some decisions that they're gonna regret later.
Nooo.
It was like traveling through time.
No shit.
It was like traveling through time and accidentally ending up in a dimension where the past is underwater and like everything is covered in barnacles.
I think Julia is stupid.
Well I like them stupid.
It was like traveling to the past but everything is underwater and everything is covered in barnacles.
And sharks.
I can't believe there's sharks in the ocean.
Did you know that?
I didn't even meet... oh wait.
I'm Brad now.
Wait, who are you?
I'm watching... oh I'm Julia.
I'm Julia.
You're Julia?
You got the short end of the stick.
I'm gonna eavesdrop.
I can read you from a mile away.
Something's up.
Oh wait.
Why are you in my cutscene?
I don't know what's going on!
Don't fuck this up!
Privacy?
Oh you got it!
Oh damn it!
Okay don't worry I'll watch from here.
Uh... yeah.
Maybe.
I mean... I don't know.
I think so.
You think so?
Well you know so.
Oh my god.
Is everything okay?
Why is he on the car?
Yeah is everything okay?
What are you gonna do?
Are you gonna ruin a 10 year relationship?
That's fine.
It's fine.
What's going on?
Look.
When we get home we can talk about some stuff.
What do you mean we can talk about some stuff?
I mean it's not like we're breaking up.
Wait what are you doing?
No!
What are you doing to our relationship?
Stop.
Got it.
Oh my god this guy.
He acts like an AI for real.
Brad is right there!
Are you a brother?
Or Fliss?
Uh no I...
Yeah I got distracted.
Let's go get him.
I got distracted with this conversation.
Wait are they like making out downstairs?
Are they?
Oh!
I did that.
You're welcome man.
I worked so hard on this for you.
Jesus Christ Conrad.
What did he do?
What's going on?
Please try to interrupt your seven seconds in heaven.
Oh yeah.
The beers.
I was just getting them now.
What?
We're not gonna address that.
We're not gonna.
We're just gonna.
Oh man you worked so hard and I brought it home run.
I brought it home for you.
And you tried to.
No.
You tried to sabotage it after I worked so hard for it.
It's a seven year relationship.
If they weren't going strong they would.
I...
My intervention would mean nothing.
Maybe we can figure out why the planes are not working.
What happened underwater man?
What happened?
Oh search for the nav pad.
What the hell is that?
You got the nav pad divemaster Jay?
Oh no.
Not yet.
What's that?
What's the nav pad?
Oh this thing.
You alright?
You seem kind of preoccupied.
Yeah.
I'm grabbing it.
Sorry.
Wait is this it?
What is this?
I'm talking to my brother.
What am I doing?
How do you think the day went?
Oh I'm looking at the pictures.
Other than our little tight at night with the locals.
Pretty good.
People always say they had diving experience.
But Alex and Julia seems to actually know what they're doing.
Air rescue service.
Conwin Islands.
So...
Oh that's me.
We going again tomorrow?
That's me.
Oh I can't wait.
Sign me up.
That's me.
Can't wait to see this sucker for myself.
What are you doing man?
We're having a conversation with everybody except for Julia.
I'm looking at the pictures.
Oh sorry.
I was looking at pictures.
You got a girlfriend?
Yeah.
Oh.
What?
Yeah.
Oh I thought it was a tablet.
I did.
What?
See I did that.
What did you do?
Women right?
Oh.
I'm making out with Alex right now.
Right here.
Wait you kissed Alex?
Yeah.
You fixed it.
You fixed the problem you caused.
Well yeah.
No I didn't.
No I did.
I caused that.
I mean I caused it.
Yes yeah you did.
You did cause it.
It's blooming.
If you did decompress too fast then you should go easy on the beer.
Alex I'm fine.
I think if I got the bends I would know by now.
I think I'm fine.
Not always.
Sometimes the bends can be super delayed.
It could be hours or a day or two.
What's the bends?
The bends?
Yeah what's the bends?
It's when you come up from a dive too fast.
Oh oh oh yeah.
Decompression sickness.
Oh.
Nerd.
Wow.
What?
All caps.
It's really serious.
Divers get sick and die from decompression sickness every year.
And that is why the good Dr. Conrad says drink them if you got them cause either you're fine or you're gonna want a little something.
I don't think I want to listen to Dr. Conrad.
Yeah.
I think Alex is an actual doctor.
Take orders from this guy just drink a beer.
Bro what?
Oh no I have to make the decision.
Man don't you dare.
You gotta listen to Conrad.
Beer o'clock.
Nerd.
Are you serious?
Oh my god if she dies it's on you.
Manchurian GOLD.
Literally doctors orders and you're like beer o'clock.
Beer o'clock.
These are coordinates all right.
Let me listen to my brother who throws money at problems.
Hey I'm not Julia.
You'll be Julia eventually.
I have to be Julia to take care of the mess you make.
I'm going to take care of the mess you made.
Wait...
Superstition?
Wait... what?
Is that it?
Really?
The dead don't sleep well in these waters.
May sound silly enough to you all, but I was raised on this shit and it sticks.
Oooh...
Are you gonna call her like a liar?
Oh come on...
Yeah...
Maybe it's not Julia being a Karen, maybe it's you.
It's a Karen.
No respect for anyone else's traditions.
I just don't like Julia.
Damn.
I don't want anyone else to like her.
I don't like Julia either.
It's bad luck.
You think you can scavenge down there and it makes no difference, but every single thing you bring back has an essence.
It's like a ghost you invite to the surface.
Here we go.
Oh my god, you're so rude!
You never think about much of anything.
You're so rude!
You made it sound...
You made her rude!
People drown in these waters and you have to respect their resting place.
Damn straight.
Fred, you got a fun ghost story, right?
Oh, I do?
Do you?
Come on, decide.
Say it.
Yeah, yeah.
Once upon a time.
Yeah, come on, let's hear it.
Ooh.
Yeah, let's hear it.
Let's hear it.
I bet you can spin a good yarn.
It's kind of messed up, actually.
Oh.
Yeah.
Scare away, little bro.
Okay, here goes.
This story is true.
It had happened right near here in an old lighthouse.
Classic setup.
Wait, what?
I thought Alex already knew the story.
Why are you deciding?
Like you don't know what's going on?
A creepy old guy.
Well, down by the dockside, I found an ancient old man, skin like a letter book, eye patch wooden legs...
Why did you wiggle up?
...you told me a secret.
For just a dollar.
Okay.
Here we go.
The lighthouse stood atop an atoll, isolated from the rest of the world.
Because it was a spooky lighthouse.
Yeah.
The lighthouse keeper would hear the sound of the light.
He heard the waves pounding the rocky shore.
Okay.
One misty morning, he comes upon a woman.
Oh.
Covered in blood.
Women?
He hurries to her aid and she falls into his arms, sobbing.
Oh my god.
As he hurries her back to the lighthouse, he asks where she's from.
He doesn't waste any time.
Smooth.
Conrad, shut up.
Conrad.
Yeah, shut up.
Shut up.
My parents are upstairs right now.
Dun dun dun.
The lighthouse keeper says, that isn't so.
I'm sorry.
He's not here.
Of course, he's lived there alone for years.
And the woman becomes hysterical.
His pupils are so dialy.
And his sister turns upstairs.
So, they go to the top of the lighthouse.
And there, splayed out on the floor, is a man and a woman.
Oh.
Totally murdered with an axe.
Oh my god.
Where's an axe?
I mean, do people even use axes anymore?
I'm just reporting the facts.
Chopped up into little tiny giblets.
Giblets?
It's a good job.
That's a good story, man.
It's a very good story.
Wow.
You tell a better story then.
You're literally the one that asked for the story.
No, Julia, like, relationship went up.
Come on, Zach.
Say it was you.
You were the...
Oh.
I'm gonna do relax.
The woman says, he was my husband.
And she turns to the closet.
Says, he's in there.
I asked the husband.
And that's why.
Oh.
She was a lighthouse keeper.
No, Alex.
No!
Alex is putting his head in his hands right now.
Sure enough, there's a man beside.
What?
But he's cut his own throat.
Oh.
He looks closer to see the dead man's face in the dark.
Closer.
And he sees...
Oh my god.
The uncanny...
It's his own face.
I know.
And then its eyes bulge out and screams.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Where did that come from?
I think Brad is possessed.
Yeah, I think I'm...
I think he's possessed.
Holy shit.
Oh, come on.
That wasn't scary.
Okay.
Do better next time, Brad.
Doki, pick better prompts next time.
Wow, I saw you scream.
I saw the screams around me.
What regular issues are these?
It's standard issue, regulatory issues...
I don't think I trust Conrad with anything.
I don't either.
I feel like he's like...
He's like that type of guy that's like, I'm gonna tell my dad what you said about me.
Yeah!
Did we not notice the storm that's incoming?
And we're on a tiny little boat that's gonna capsize.
Uh-oh.
Oh no, now there's a storm.
I think we're in trouble.
I think we fucked up.
I think we messed up, yeah.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
You think those guys are gonna come back and...
The fishermen?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Where did they come from?
Did you bring stuff up to the ship?
It was the tablet!
You brought a tablet?!
That's why we looked at the gold!
Uh-oh.
They have opposable thumbs.
They're fine.
We're fine.
They're looking over us.
Is that the ship?
That guy looks human.
Wait, are they the pirates?
Oh my god, he's got a gun!
Oh my god.
What do I...
I tried right-triggering, but it didn't let me do anything.
I think he's about to die.
What did you do?
Did you not do your quick time offense?
I couldn't figure out where I was supposed to go!
Oh my god!
I did my quick time offense!
What the hell?!
Look at where it's gotten you.
You're still trapped too.
Because you failed the quick time offense!
I tried to get the gun from his head!
Where's Brad?
Oh, there's Fliss.
Oh, there they are!
That's the fishermen!
That's the pirates!
I told you!
This guy means business.
Why'd you piss him off?
Why did Conrad piss him off?!
Because you pissed him off!
You threw money at them!
It's your fault!
I can't control Conrad!
Nobody can control Conrad!
It's your fault!
Oh, you're deciding.
Okay, Conrad, what's your genius idea this time?
What is she doing?
She's crying on his...
What is happening?
I don't know!
I don't want to do this!
Oh, oh, but I missed my event.
That was my fault.
I'm trying to... I'm trying to do this right now!
Did you miss it?
You missed it!
There was no... Okay.
Oh, no, oh, no.
You're so good at this.
I have to choose.
You do it then.
You're gonna see what I meant.
Yeah?
I did it!
How did you do it?
I had to choose between Conrad and Julia.
Okay, let me try this again.
How did you do it?
This is how we're gonna die.
I right trigger and then I pull with the right.
I'm trying to pull!
Let me pull!
So I lose your right.
I swear!
I do it!
I swear to God!
This will never be...
Alright, you fucking do it again.
I'll do it!
Okay, watch this.
It's so easy.
I don't understand!
How did you do that?
How did you?
How did you do it?
Okay, your turn.
Oh, never mind!
Oh, no.
Why is he bleeding?
Where's Brad?
Oh, no.
Hey!
I gotta turn the sound down again on this thing.
It's so bad.
I don't understand!
How did you guys do it?
Wow, you let Fliss die because you couldn't un-gag her.
I can't understand!
How did you do it?
Hey, so, uh...
What's the good news?
The bad news is these are kinda...
maybe the fishermen I pissed off earlier...
Oh my God, Conrad!
...just great!
And the good news?
I recognize them.
What?
How's that good news?
They're such an idiot!
Jesus!
Oh, wait.
Um...
I'm gonna untie him.
We have to get free, right now!
Yeah, come here.
Come here, Conrad.
Put on some pants, man!
Wait, did you have to hold your pants?
Did you hold down the right stick?
Until it came off?
Yes!
Why did you say that?
I told you!
Look, look.
I didn't realize you had to hold it.
Who's the gamer now?
You failed your QuickTime event twice.
What?
It was just the gun!
Oh my God, this guy...
Oh, sit back down.
Sit back down, idiot.
Wouldn't they think it's weird that we're un-gagged?
I know, right?
Alright.
I succeeded my QuickTime event.
Did you?
I did mine!
Okay.
I stopped you from getting...
beat up.
Conrad kinda deserves it, though.
Wait, Conrad's gone.
Bye, Conrad.
Wait, are you getting taken away?
Yeah.
I'm seeing what's happening.
Oh, shit.
You can go fuck yourself, you piece of shit.
You're the little lady.
What's happening?
Oh, so like, the guy was like, you're fucked.
Oh, and then Conrad gets punched.
I saw that.
Oh, where is he going?
Oh!
Oh my God, they're taking him out.
I mean, if they kill Conrad, that's okay, right?
They're beating Conrad!
We don't care about that, right?
I'm making Julia scared.
Okay, what do you want?
What do you fuckers want?
Okay, I didn't say fuckers.
I said...
Wait, they're actually killing Conrad!
You did this!
I just said, what do you want?
Please, just stop.
Y'all, you pissed him off.
Uh-oh.
Oh, wait, they have the gun?
Oh no, it's a knife!
I'm gonna say nothing.
Don't say anything!
If I say something, I feel like they're gonna...
They're gonna get agitated.
What?
What is that?
I saved Conrad, you're welcome.
No, why would you want to save Conrad?
Because you told me to!
You literally told me to!
Oh, I got a cuticle cutter.
I'm cutting the ropes!
I'm gonna say nothing again.
Oh, they're coming back!
I feel like if I say something, they would agitate him more.
Oh, he's coming back!
I'm back!
I'm back, Conrad!
I saved Conrad just for you, Min!
I've kissed you love, Conrad, so much!
I wanna see him get us killed even in a different way.
Yeah, I feel like you have higher survivability if he's dead.
Oh my god!
Alex, why did you get up so slowly?
You have no restraint!
Just open the door!
Uh,
wait.
What's going on?
You're in.
Uh, I'm with Conrad and Alex.
Oh, you're with us?
Oh, wait, whoa!
You're Conrad!
No, I'm Alex!
Oh, I'm Conrad!
I'm sure he's fine.
These guys probably just want money or something.
Yeah.
Man, if I let Conrad die here, I wouldn't have to be forced to play Conrad.
Everyone has to play Conrad at least once.
Even you, Chad.
Everyone has to feel the shame of being Conrad.
I thought he was gonna die.
Except by saving Conrad, you will have to deal with Conrad later.
No, they knew that you liked him so much.
I literally saved him for you!
What did they do to Julia?
Are you okay?
Are you okay, little Julia?
Are you okay, little girl?
Okay.
What?
Oh.
It's gonna be a hostage situation.
Yeah.
There you go.
Nice.
What if everybody dies but Conrad?
Should we do that?
Make it a mission?
Keep Conrad alive!
Is he just counting?
Yeah.
What is he counting?
Oh, I think he's seeing the time between the lightning and the thunder.
Oh.
That's smart.
Yeah, he is.
Wow.
Spoken like a true Conrad.
Nerd.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a speedboat.
The main guy here.
He's got a gun.
Uh oh.
Uh, I'm gonna... you know.
Well, at least one of us can get on the boat.
We're gonna get on that boat.
Oh.
Right.
Okay, I'm gonna say nothing.
So you have to get on the boat.
Oh, what do you think?
She's asking you.
We gotta break these off first.
Oh.
That's you.
No, I didn't say anything!
Yes, you're gonna get through the window.
Yeah, good call!
No, Conrad!
Conrad the ghoul!
No!
I said nothing!
Okay, sneaking mission.
Oh no.
Oh no, please.
I don't wanna be Conrad anymore.
Three!
No!
I have to be Conrad!
Uh oh.
Go Conrad!
Go!
Yeah.
Is this me?
Is this my quick time event?
Oh shoot.
Ah!
Don't fuck this up!
Um, I might have fucked it up a little bit.
What did you do?
I'm doing my quick time event right now!
I thought you said X.
What did you do?!
I'm escaping.
Oh, Bradley!
Get out of here!
Get out of here, Conrad!
Go live!
Live a long life!
Oh my god!
I did it!
I think Fliss is gonna die.
I got... I have a hostage!
I have a hostage!
I went... I went and escaped.
I didn't grab a knife.
What?!
What do you mean?!
What do you mean?
Wait, what did you do?
I have a guy hostage.
I'm gonna kill him.
Oh my god!
There you are like Spider-Man!
Goodbye!
Conrad's leaving!
Wait, I think they're gonna shoot me!
No!
They're gonna shoot Conrad!
Attack him!
I don't care about you, Julie!
Oh, I tried.
I really did try.
Oh my god.
Is he dead?
Did you dodge it?
Conrad's escaped!
We did it!
We saved Conrad!
Conrad lives!
We did it guys!
Conrad is dead!
Thank god I was Conrad and doing the quick time event.
I saved you!
I could've shielded Julia!
But I saved you instead.
Yeah, cause you know we needed to save Conrad!
She is gone!
Oh my god!
A little big adventure.
He's just Conrad.
Oh my god, we did it guys.
Apparently, people were like, people usually never save Conrad.
He usually dies there.
Conrad deserves better.
Conrad?
We did it guys!
He's gonna be the hero in the end.
Yeah!
He's gonna do it.
Is the sound effects down real quick?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm turning them down again.
I'm gonna turn down as well.
I can't believe it.
They're like, usually Conrad gets shot.
I don't know how you guys save him.
We have our priorities straight.
Absolutely.
Okay, I'm good.
The only two people who saved Conrad.
Willingly.
Not for like completionist sake.
Okay.
We're hostages.
Cool.
What do we do now?
She's like looking for him.
Why do you make all the important decisions?
Connie!
Shut the fuck up!
Why can't you wipe the blood off your face?
We were only talking.
There's no harm in just talking.
Yeah.
We practically won the game.
We have one survivor so we basically won.
I'm just gonna say it.
Fliss has gotta be in on this.
What the fuck?
You threw Fliss at it?
That bus?
They barely laid a hand on her?
I bet you told them about the Manchurian gold.
They're in Cahoot.
They don't even know about the gold!
Why did you tell them about the gold?
Oh my god!
Well, Fliss, what do you have to say?
I can't believe what I'm hearing.
I just lost everything I have.
And this is what you think?
What do you mean you lost everything?
I lost my boat!
This is my boat!
Put a cork in it.
Oh my god.
Oh dang it.
That quick time event was to save Julia?
Oh, Fliss again.
Cahoots, cahoots, cahoots!
What happened to Brad?
Brad is right next to me!
Why not?
Why won't you talk to me?
Move the gun.
We should save Julia next.
Save all the way.
We'll save the worst people.
They can have each other.
Julia and her brother.
Conrad.
How bad is the storm?
Hey, just requesting any information about this storm you can give us?
Why do you like this?
Big storm coming in from the east.
I know, I'm just talking to you, man.
Master your coordinates within an hour.
Uh...
Should I provoke them, you guys?
Or what should I do?
I literally was compliant.
I'm not.
Okay, my discord is here.
We can handle a couple of buffs and drops of rain.
Thanks for the info.
We'll see you for drinks back on shore in a couple of days.
Look, I'm being compliant.
I listen.
Look, he's being a little baby.
What the fuck are you doing down there?
Why are you fucking trying to make sure we don't die?
And you're on your pee.
Where are you?
You're antagonizing the fucking other pirates.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Quick time event.
Quick time.
Oh.
Whoa.
I got both of mine.
Did you?
I got mine too.
Okay.
Alright.
I doubt it.
The water...
At least you're downstairs.
I'm upstairs.
What?
Our ship is flooding.
We're gonna drown.
Wait.
What's going on?
The ship is flooding.
Oh my god.
There you guys are.
We're drowning.
I'm gonna hold on.
I'm gonna rescue Brad instead.
Get out of here, Brad.
Get out of here.
I hope you guys are okay.
Because I had a choice to save.
But I chose not to.
Hey.
Move it.
We're gonna drown.
Oh my god.
Why was there so much water in there?
Because we're in the ocean.
The water's not supposed to go in the boat.
I had to help Brad.
Good job looking after number one.
Real smooth.
Great leadership, Fliss.
What did I do?
I literally saved us by...
Brad can't help himself.
He's a little baby.
Uh-oh.
What the fuck is that?
Oh my god.
We found the ship.
We found Madonne.
Yeah.
There's Madonne.
There it is.
Oh my god.
Get in there.
There's Madonne.
The man.
That was the man of him.
Yeah.
That's the man.
The man of the Madonne.
Oh my god.
Wait.
That wasn't Conrad.
You don't think, right?
No, because...
No, we saved him.
Did we save him?
Yeah.
We did it.
We're keeping people alive.
I think he's disappointed in us.
I think he wanted Conrad to die.
What do you mean?
Yeah.
I saved some... Yeah.
I would have done it too if it wasn't you.
Yeah.
It was a QuickTime event.
I don't think you would have.
I did all my QuickTime events.
Most of them.
The kind-hearted creature I am, I'd like to offer you some forewarning of what's to come.
Do you want to see it?
Ooh.
Tempted?
We can decide.
Wait.
Do you want to know or not?
I want to know.
How do you...
Okay.
Let's know.
Curious?
I got to make the decision.
Yeah.
You're in agreement.
Clue it is.
Yeah.
The merchant of Venice, Act 2, Scene 7.
The Prince of Morocco pulls a scroll from the eye of a skull and reads, All that glisters is not gold.
Glisters?
Often have you heard that told.
What the fuck does that mean?
I don't...
What?
That was a hint.
That's not even a bit.
It's barely a riddle.
What?
Everything may not be entirely as it seems.
He quoted Smash Mouth.
All that glisters is gold.
Probably shouldn't have said that.
Oh, don't be greedy.
I meant don't be greedy.
I'm not.
You is you.
Don't you get the tablet?
I had to to progress.
I think.
Oh yeah, I did.
You're Julia now.
Oh no.
You're Fliss.
Oh, I'm Fliss now.
Okay, this is my first time being Fliss.
Oh no, now I'm Julia.
Now to fix the relationship you've ruined.
Yeah.
Like I said, if they were truly happy for those seven years, my little tiny decisions did nothing.
But how many tiny decisions did you make?
There was like...
No decisions.
Why are we going to the... that ship?
Why can't we stay in our little ship?
What is that?
Oh, what they found?
It's a dynamite, isn't it?
What?
I don't think so.
What was that?
Why did they suddenly decide to search in there?
I know, that's what I'm saying.
Why can't we just stay in our tiny ship?
Oh, it's an engine part.
Oh.
Oh, apparently it was sinking.
What the hell is wrong with you?
Yeah, that's what I said.
And you were like, we're in the ocean.
How was I supposed to know we were sinking?
I thought just water got in.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we're Ollie.
We're all gonna die in here.
Yeah, we're gonna die in the ship of Madon.
But we know Brad would live in the bathroom here.
No, that was the bathroom of the other boat.
No, it was the bathroom of this boat.
No, I don't think so.
Right?
It was blue.
The ship is blue.
It was... Oh, we're walking now.
Oh, we are.
I was gonna say stay here.
Hey, remember you can walk faster.
LB.
Oh, LB, LB.
I'm walking, I'm walking.
I'm walking here.
I got a thing.
What is this?
Guard duty.
Oh, he's watching me.
He's watching you?
Hey!
I was reading that!
Yeah, stop reading!
This guy sucks.
You're supposed to be walking!
I'm walking.
Be careful.
I'm doing my job.
I'm gonna get tetanus.
Oh, who are you walking into?
Oh, I walk...
Oh, oh.
Oh, he pushed me too.
Is this...
Okay, my bad, my bad, my bad.
We're walking, we're walking.
Apparently we can't even walk right.
Here we go.
Oh!
Oh no, your little bracelet!
Oh my god, no.
No, my bracelet!
That's like $100,000.
Oh, your bracelet.
Daddy bought it for me.
Here we go.
Real gold.
Yeah, I got it from...
What's wrong with your head?
Ah!
Oh, that's a dead body.
Am I able to walk?
Am I walking?
Oh wait, oh wait, oh yeah, we're walking.
Oh, I got pushed back.
Sorry, I walked the wrong way.
You look a little worried.
What's wrong?
Where do we go?
Oh, Scooby, where do we go?
Oh gosh, Shaggy, I don't know...
Oh gosh!
I don't know about this, Shaggy.
Let's go.
Rocky, I don't know about this, Rocky.
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh, wait.
Wait, what is that?
What is that?
I can't even move.
I want to see what the poster says.
The Mask of Madness.
The Mask?
If you dare to look death in the eye, now showing in the mess hall.
Whoa!
Are you...
Do you see what I'm seeing?
I'm in the dormitories.
What are you seeing?
I don't know.
I'm just walking.
Oh, I can see...
There's an item here.
Grab it?
What are they gonna do with us?
Oh, there's Miller.
What?
Miller.
Why are they like not...
They're not supervising us anymore.
I know.
Where are they?
Oh, I can also look at it.
What is it?
It says Miller.
Miller.
I'm waiting for you here.
I'm at the other side.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
Master Miller?
Oh, there's Alex.
Oh, they're slow.
They're just as slow as we are.
I don't think LB works.
I'll be honest.
I don't feel any faster.
I don't think so, though.
I don't think it works either.
Why is every...
Why is he moving like he's one of us?
Like he's...
He's moving like an MP.
Oh, there's rats.
Rats?
Where's the...
Where's the rats, Roggy?
I didn't see any rats.
I didn't...
Oh, Roggy.
There's something over here.
Oh.
What's this?
It's an internal memorandum.
This is gonna give us a hint?
You're covering Patterson's guard duties tomorrow.
He is sick again.
Conveniently, it's always when he has guard duties and hold 3A.
First is 24 o'clock.
Check the chart for...
Oh.
Oh, you found the secret.
Maybe that'll help us.
This is the third time this week.
None of us like it down there.
Maybe Patterson should buck up.
Get...
Just get on it.
Okay.
Maybe it'll...
Maybe it'll like help us.
Hello.
I wanna look at the secret, too.
Yeah, go look at the secret.
I wanna look at it.
How do I look at the secret?
It might be in the menu now, right?
No!
I think so.
Yeah, I think you got the secret, so I don't have to look at the secret.
That's two for two secrets for me.
Okay.
So, let's go.
I'm gonna go see the secret.
Okay.
I'm gonna go check the secret.
There's lots of doors here.
Yeah.
Are they putting us in the brig?
Wait, this is where we were, isn't it?
When we were Konrad and...
No, we were never here.
I don't remember this area.
Oh!
We're locked in!
Oh my God.
Hey!
It's pitch black in here!
Give us the light.
Where did that light come from?
It doesn't look like it.
Oh, they gave us a flat... they're such nice pirates!
They're actually so nice!
See, their pirates aren't that bad.
I bet they weren't actually gonna shoot Conrad.
Wait, how do we have a lighter?
Gosh, I almost missed that.
My controller was like in my lap.
How is that still good?
Like, not waterlogged.
I know.
Wait, maybe because the ship never went into the ocean.
What's the ship's name?
Oh, wow.
Your relationship with Alex went down!
How did it go down?
I literally just asked about the ship's name!
You're so... okay, what is this relationship we're trying to save, huh?
Wait for Brad... um...
We should just leave.
I didn't know that meant we...
Oh yeah, good luck.
How would the radio still be working?
I know, right?
It's been like, out of commission for so long.
Wait, but I thought it was sinking!
If it was sinking, then...
How is the ship gonna be still there?
Yeah, exactly.
I don't think it was sinking.
I don't think so.
You told me it was sinking!
That's why I agreed with you!
You're the one that told me it was sinking!
No, you said it first!
I didn't!
I was like, why don't we just take the ship and you're like, no, it's sinking, Toki!
No, we're working with these guys.
Whatever.
But I... I mean, obviously that's not true.
They're being just as bad to you as they are to us.
No, it was water.
We were drowning.
There's water everywhere!
Just get a fucking bucket!
Oh my god, it was Julius who was just like, we're gonna drown!
Oh, hey, we apologized to each other.
Cool.
After we were arguing with each other, they apologized.
I know.
We did our job.
Secured a room.
Oh, I got something here too.
What's happening?
I don't know, we were too busy arguing.
I know.
Okay.
What's this?
Oh, I found a secret.
Hey, baby doll.
I miss you like crazy.
Three months until my next leave and jumping into your arms.
Three months.
I've been on the shore leave with these guys.
Had a few beers, but don't worry, I'm keeping everything ready for you.
If you catch my drift.
How's work?
I hope that boss of yours is leaving you alone.
I know you can take care of yourself, but I feel helpless being so far away and I want to keep you safe.
Skydive.
I got a lot of time to think while I'm guarding the cargo holds.
It's dark and spooky down there.
Some of the other guys have seen a figure roaming around, but I've always got you with me to keep me safe too.
I'll be with you soon and get a job as a mechanic.
And we can get married and have two children.
We'll be happy.
Happy together.
Forever.
Love you so much, Miller.
Oh my god!
Look at the picture on the wall!
What picture?
This one.
Right here.
Oh, okay.
Is that gonna give us a secret?
Yeah.
Alright.
And like look at it and then like look up.
Are you good?
I don't know.
What's wrong?
I wonder what happened.
Alright, I'm looking up.
Wait, it won't let me look up.
What do you mean?
With the right analog.
It didn't let me.
What?
It didn't let me look up.
You missed the secret.
I missed the secret?
No!
No.
But I wanna look at that too.
Move!
I'm listening to the... Do you know French?
Yeah.
Oui?
He says, I don't have the tools to do as I say and that's all.
I'm live translating.
Fuck you.
I'm live translating for you.
Oh, okay.
Thanks.
Nothing asshole.
Stop.
Stop it.
Shut up, Junior.
You're sitting there watching the prisoners.
Prisoners?
This is a real Canadian moment.
Is that... Is this a prison?
Do you not have subtitles on?
You don't have subtitles on, do you?
No, I do.
I have them on.
What?
I can't you see the subtitles at the bottom?
Yeah, but what if you weren't looking at them?
I'm talking to the boyfriend.
I found a letter.
A really weird letter.
Some of the crew were really...
I'm still listening to these guys.
...wicked out.
By what?
The guy Miller who wrote it says he saw figures roaming around.
Figures?
Oh, I'm telling him... I'm telling Alex about the ghosts.
Like ghosts?
Oh, I'm gonna listen.
I saw the rest of the guys were just trying to scare me.
What the hell was that?
Hold on.
I'm stuck.
I can't get over there.
Hold on.
I see you.
I can't get over there.
How did you get over there?
I'm coming.
LBLD.
About this whole shit.
I just wish I knew what...
Yeah, I wanna know what the fisherman's gonna be doing.
Yeah.
Oh, there you are.
Are they gonna let us go if they find all that gold?
And if they don't find any gold...
What the fuck happened?
What happened?
Alex just disappeared on my screen.
What did you do, Alex?
What are you doing?
Oh, my God.
That is very hopeful.
Where the fuck is Brad in all of this?
He's in the room somewhere.
He's just existing.
Okay, in the end, we gotta make sure Julia survives.
Yeah.
There was some stuff over here.
There is one over here.
I'm staring.
What's this?
You got it?
You got this.
Yeah, I know how to hold now.
I know.
I found a pen!
You're pushing me out of the way!
I did it.
I did it, Mint.
Nice.
Oh, what's this?
No!
I found it!
A way out.
That's the game we're playing.
How am I... oh, there.
Wait, what's this?
There's a newspaper.
Oh, secret found.
1947.
Archaeologists missing in Iraq.
24 British archaeologists have gone missing in the mountains of Iraq.
The Hudson expedition arrived in the kingdom in September last year with a starting goal unearthing.
And then...
Oh, this must be the thing we found in the cargo.
Yeah.
This could be the cargo thing.
That's why they're all possessed and...
Yeah.
They're cursed.
This is cursed.
Is there anything else we missed in here?
Oh, what's this?
Oh my god, Bradley's scared as crap.
I found Glam.
Oh my god, there he is.
Right there.
Oh my god, he's scared me so bad.
He just doesn't do anything.
He's useless.
We know somebody that's not gonna survive.
I can't get it open.
We can get it open.
We're not keeping Bradley alive, right?
No, Bradley can die.
Yeah, Brad's just gonna die.
Down with the nerd.
No nerds allowed.
We can get it open.
Freedom.
Oh, uh...
This is the way out.
Yeah.
My excitement's going up.
Alright, I got this.
No, I got this.
Yeah.
Someone should create a distraction.
This is gonna be loud.
Alex relationships.
Oh, Julia goes up.
Oh.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, wait, Fliss.
Yeah, you make a distraction.
Yeah, why don't you do the distraction?
I'm gonna distract.
Here I go.
I hope Fliss doesn't die.
Finally get away.
Oh, maybe I shouldn't let you distract.
Yeah, hey, all that stuff she said but double is gross.
And your mother's mother's too.
Whoa.
Don't talk about my mom.
Oh, are you...
I'm doing the quick time event.
Oh, thank God I'm doing the quick time event.
That's right.
Your mother's all sucking.
Let us out.
Yeah, your mother.
Yeah, dear.
Yeah.
Are they coming?
Why are you screaming?
Because they don't want them there.
They want to hear us doing the event.
We're already done, Fliss.
Shut up.
Fliss, come on.
What do you mean?
You're Fliss.
Wait, what's going on?
Come on, Fliss.
Fliss.
Fliss, come on.
There you go.
Nice.
God, I can't believe she's not wearing shoes.
What are you deciding?
Replace it.
Yeah, they'll never know.
They'll never know.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
We're gonna get separated at some point.
I feel like it, too.
Find a way off the ship.
We need to keep going.
Come on.
There's gotta be some stairs around here.
Okay.
What's going on?
Wait, why am I holding the light?
Wait, who am I?
Wait, who are you?
You're always... wait, are you Alex?
I'm Alex.
Oh, you're Alex?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, now that we're... oh wait, there's something over here too.
There's stuff in here, yeah.
They're all leaving, but we gotta explain.
We're splitting up already, guys?
We're splitting up.
I found a piece of paper.
It's good to know that we're splitting up already.
I found the guard duty regulations.
I found the uniforms.
Wait, how do I... oh, there we go.
Guys, nobody is allowed into 3A.
Seriously.
Okay, guys, I'm coming back.
Where are you?
No alcohol.
Where are you, Mint?
Hold on, I'm right by the front door.
The door we just... here, look at me.
Turn around.
I'm turning around?
Where are you?
I'm right in front of you.
I already ran through that door.
There's nothing in there.
I already ran through that.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, Mint, I think we're gonna get caught up by the pirates.
No, why are you looking at me?
Why are you looking down like that?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm trying to look at where I'm standing.
I'm the one with the lights.
Oh, there's another door.
I have a flashlight too.
But how do you have a... oh, wait, I found a map.
Why is the light flickering there?
Out of bounds.
What was that?
Okay, so, Cargo Hole 2 is out of bounds.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, are you gonna remember... do you remember that?
Cargo Hole 2 is out of bounds.
Yeah, when are we gonna get to Cargo Hole 2?
Wait, where do we go?
Why was the light flashing over there?
Yeah, you first.
Here?
You first.
Oh.
What's going on in here?
What's going on?
We're already split up with this.
Do lights actually work?
Oh my god.
Oh, oh, wait, I'm in the bathroom.
I'm in the bathroom.
Oh, I found a light in the bathroom!
Ladies first.
All right.
It's reading time.
Dear Eyeless, I'm finally coming home.
This is it, darling.
One last trip across the Pacific and I'll be back to you and the girls.
I can't wait to see your faces.
Tell Ned and Nancy to get excited.
They're gonna see Daddy real soon and he's got gifts for y'all.
I'm sure glad to be back at sea.
It's hotter than an Oklahoma summer out there on the land and there's no escape from it.
I've been all right because I got your letters to keep me going.
They censored them, which is probably for the best, because sometimes the others steal them to read and I don't like them reading them.
I'm glad I'm reading our letters.
It really creeps me out.
It keeps telling me there's a little boy on board and it sounds like Ted.
What?
Wait, don't eat.
Our feet are smelly.
Oh, oh, we gotta go.
We gotta go.
I didn't finish the reading and...
Oh, I didn't.
We gotta go.
I think that's the sign.
We gotta get out of here, man.
Guys, I think...
I think...
Roro.
Scooby.
Scoob.
Where did they go?
I think...
Oh, this way.
I think the moment it starts getting smelly, that's when death is coming and we split up.
Yeah!
We split up with...
No, no, they're right here.
They're right here.
They're right in front of me.
All right.
I like how we're the only ones with the flashlight and we're like back.
In the very back.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
There's a lot of people who are suspiciously nowhere to be found.
Oh, wait.
There's stuff here.
Yeah, there's something here.
Oh, what's that?
What is that?
Are you picking it?
Oh.
Are you picking it up?
I think it's a skull of a rat.
Oh, there's another thing here, too.
It's a rat.
So my chat was like, I sure love how all the letters are like, gosh, I'm happy to be alive.
Wait, what happened?
Oh, my God.
What happened?
I just got grabbed by a ghost hand.
What?
Skipper has Kato'd the booze for this goddamn trip.
Okay.
None of this lore.
This lore is not interesting.
He's just talking about alcohol.
It has to be the sound effects, right?
Or is it the music that goes... I think I'm gonna... hold on.
I think it's the music.
No, it's so bad!
I think it's the music that's going down to 35.
You got the spooky... got the 35.
That must have been some spooky music.
It was so loud.
Oh my god.
Wait, how are you scared of ghosts?
You are a ghost.
I'm scared of jump scares.
Yeah, but it's just your neighbor grabbing your hand.
I don't know.
Look at our feet!
Wait, oh, I could grab... wait, okay, I wanna see what this jump scare is.
Oh yeah, yeah, you do the rat.
Do the rat.
I'll do the rat.
Oh.
Oh, I'm looking at it.
I'm watching.
Am I going crazy?
There's nothing.
You lied to me.
There was nothing there.
What?
You're going crazy.
You didn't take your meds.
I have smelly feet.
Okay, I have smelly feet.
It's not my fault.
It's not my fault!
Someone here was lying.
Uh -oh.
Oh, I found a picture frame.
I think this is a clue.
Is this a premonition?
Yeah.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
What?
What is it?
Um...
What is the premonition?
You might wanna look at that one.
Okay.
We gotta make sure nobody dies.
Yeah, I think...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
All right, we gotta make sure Alex doesn't die.
You're Alex.
It's in your hands.
No, I got no...
It already warned you how to save Alex.
I don't know what was going on there.
They already told you how to save.
Oh my god, Bradley doesn't have shoes either.
What's wrong with you guys?
Mint has to protect herself.
It's not my fault.
Hey.
Um, I'm dead, so that means I couldn't protect myself from the beginning.
Oh my god, the flashlight.
Turn down the flashlight.
Turn it off!
There's someone down there, all right.
I'm the loudest whisperer ever.
Just turn it off.
Why are you putting your hand over a flashlight?
Oh, there's the pirates.
Save the battery, man.
Could be those charging flashlights, you know?
The...
Wah-wah-wah.
The whirring ones.
Are we actually gonna get that?
Yeah, I'm sure.
Yeah, we gotta get that so we can leave, right?
Oh no.
Oh?
He's gonna break it.
He's gonna destroy it so nobody can use it.
Oh, nevermind.
What's he doing?
He grabbed a weapon.
He has a hammer, yeah.
Um...
I don't need you barking at me.
I swear to god, if I have to play Fliss because of that, I swear to god, man.
I swear to fucking god.
Not the flare.
Well, she was the one who was like, I'm gonna go get it.
I'm gonna go.
Oh.
Oh, you're going back in.
Bradley's a hero now.
Brad, Brad, Brad.
Brad, Brad.
All right, who's gonna be Brad and who's gonna be Fliss?
Uh oh.
All right, if I'm getting Brad, I'm making sure he dies.
Just so you know.
Oh yeah, if I get Brad, I'll do the same.
Oh my god.
Um...
No, I won't warn Brad.
How do you do it?
Brad is the victim.
Oh my god.
07 Brad.
We were very clear that we don't want Brad anymore.
Brad has been voted off the island.
Oh my god.
What?
Oh no.
Fliss.
He sounds really concerned.
Where are the others?
Oh no.
Fliss.
Oh no, the other pirates are coming over.
This is such a long cutscene.
Oh my god, don't gasp like that.
Oh wait, it's the gun.
It's the guy with the gun.
Stop screaming.
I'm trying to hear what's going on.
I'm not screaming.
Stop screaming.
I want to know where the others are.
Oh.
Bye Fliss.
Brad.
Oh my god.
Brad?
Oh my god, who's Brad?
Who's gonna be doing it?
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Alright, I see you.
Oh come on, Brad.
What the hell?
That's not us.
It's the AI.
Yeah, it's the AI.
Wow, you guys.
Come on.
Don't let him out of your sight.
Okay.
Girl, you're holding a whole ass lantern.
I think it's our...
I think...
No, it's your fault.
You literally told Fliss to go down there and get the thing.
I mean, she should have...
She was the one who brought it up in the first place.
Rat.
That's a very sick rat.
Oh, you're Fliss?
Am I Fliss?
Yes.
Now, why would I tell you?
Uh oh.
We're split up.
Wait, what are you?
Who are...
Are you Julia?
I'm Alex.
Are you Alex?
Yeah.
Are you getting...
Are you...
Oh, no.
We're split up.
This is you.
Are they interrogating you?
No, we're just...
We're just walking.
We're walking somewhere.
Oh, okay.
All right.
We went somewhere else.
I might...
We might have these two die.
What?
Are you sacrificing Fliss so that...
No, I said both of us.
No, Fliss is cool.
You're the one that go down.
Fliss, you're fucking...
Go down there?
No, she...
It was her idea.
She said, I'm gonna go down there and get it.
And I said, okay.
Do it, bet.
That's what I said to her.
Leave that alone.
Oh my God.
Julia looks really scary.
She just looks like a...
She looks so scary just standing there in the middle of the walkway.
Yeah, we like Fliss.
We don't want Fliss to die.
You're the one that sent Fliss down there.
You had a choice not to send Fliss down there.
She probably...
She wasn't gonna listen to me.
Let's be honest.
She was gonna be like, I'm going down there.
What do you want me to do?
We don't know that.
You gave her the choice.
Fliss was telling you to do it.
No, she...
No, she wasn't.
She said, I'm gonna go get that.
And then my choice was tell her don't or go get it.
And she made her choice.
She should...
She could have been like...
Yeah, but you said go get it.
You chose go get it, didn't you?
I'm stuck.
Hold on.
Where is Fliss?
Where's the door?
Hold on.
Okay, everybody.
I'm stuck.
You guys, I'm stuck.
Oh my God.
There's a dead guy.
Uh-oh.
Oh, it was just a hat.
JK.
I'm stuck.
I'm so stuck.
How do I get through here?
So, we have a very paranoid gunsman.
He's very scared.
Is he experiencing...
Oh, there we go.
He's like, I'm stuck.
Is he experiencing...
No!
What's going on?
What's going on on your side?
I'm fine.
Everything's fine.
I have a hat now.
We have?
Yeah.
I got...
Medan.
I got Medan's hat.
What?
You got the man.
I got the man.
Of Medan.
Wait.
Hold on.
There's gotta be stuff in here to find.
All right.
There were screams.
There's not a dead body in here.
There's not a dead body.
Medan.
There's screams on my end.
You're...
Take your meds.
Don't look.
It's fine.
There's scary stuff over here.
I just saw some organs.
Okay.
Chill.
Calm down.
You saw organs?
Yes.
They were organs.
They were like live organs.
Somehow they were live in the...
Wait.
What?
You found a secret.
Oh.
I found...
I found a beef casserole.
Oh Christ.
No way.
That guy...
Tuesday was cereal.
That guy's probably still right here with us.
You died, didn't you?
You're both dead, are you?
Home fried potatoes.
Boiled eggs.
I found a body.
There's no idea what you're talking about.
I found...
You're like cereal.
Back on jokey side.
Cereal, potatoes.
There's a body.
I found a body.
I found...
That's not until...
That's not until Fridays.
Come on.
Body is not on the menu yet.
Wait.
There's soup here.
You want some?
But we gotta keep moving and find Olsen.
Oh.
Now.
Soup du jour, Matt.
I found another secret.
Oh my God, Julia.
There's no time for messing around.
Alex.
God.
Oh no.
The stinky feet is here.
Oh, I have to go.
I have stinky feet too.
I just noticed.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Where are...
Why did we split up?
It's fine.
Oh.
There's a child.
I think there's running children again.
You're really...
Okay.
You're really in trouble.
I haven't seen anything yet.
I remember the last time there was running children.
Uh oh.
Wait.
So I heard something.
What did I hear?
I found a notebook.
It says...
What does it say?
Uh, nothing.
I can't even open...
Open the notebook, idiot.
Oh, I just...
Oh, there we go.
Oh.
Okay.
It's a diary.
Oh, read it.
Read that diary.
June 18th, Wednesday.
We hadn't been at sea long and I'm sick of the damn food already.
That muck we ate tonight was a joke.
The cooks do their best with what we got, I'm sure.
But man, I'd kill for something fresh.
First thing I'm doing with my life is to eat.
And when I get home is having me a tall glass of milk.
June 19th, Thursday.
Every one of the US papers was talking about that massacre in Philly.
Are these guys American or...?
All I'm saying is while you're reading this diary, our kidnapper fucking died.
I can't...
I'm just like, listen, you ate the diary and a kidnapper died.
It's crazy to think how we're out here traveling the world trying to keep our country safe when there's people killing each other in the streets back home.
I could sure use a beer after reading about how the captain has issued a ban on booze.
Guess I'll be counting sheep tonight.
Oh my god, there's more?
Oh no.
Oh my god, there's more.
Oh!
We found a secret!
Who found a secret?
Was it you?
No, oh wait, I found it.
Yeah, I found the secret!
June 20th, Friday.
Some of the guys had a little wrestling competition in one of the cargo holds today.
I did okay, but Wagner eventually knocked me out of it.
I joked he should be disqualified on account of his size, but no dice.
I like how you're reading it.
I'm trying to find a way out and you're just standing there reading the diary.
It took a whole crowd of people to pin him down.
He certainly ain't eating the same as the rest of us.
That's for sure.
June 21st, Saturday.
I'm sure the cargo we have in the hold has something to do with the squad that went missing.
Their leader, Jones, heard a legend about a room full of ancient solid gold statues from a Manchurian child emperor.
Oh, the child!
They were said to be cursed, but that sounds like a load of baloney.
It's the child!
Also, Min, I hope to god that you're heading over to where I'm heading over, because I'm progressing right now.
I'm reading!
I'm progressing!
It's knowledge, okay?
I don't know if they found them, but they never did return from their mission.
Maybe they're returning now.
Okay, that's all of it.
Cool.
Alright, cool.
I got away and I'm back in the cargo hold.
Oh, I'm far.
I don't know where I am.
Yeah, I could tell.
I could tell.
Oh, I got the knife.
I heard something, though.
I think I'm starting to hear people.
Uh oh.
Wait, I see a premonition picture!
Oh, I see a premonition picture!
I'm getting a premonition.
I'm getting a premonition right now.
What was your premonition?
Mine was the one where, like, it was a guy in a hood with a stick.
Oh my god!
I just saw Bradley's death!
Wait, how does he die?
How does he...
Wait, what is someone...
I just picked up the knife!
...wearing a raincoat.
Why'd you pick up the knife?
No, he was the one that was holding the...
I didn't know!
I picked up the knife!
I literally just picked up the knife while you said that.
Oh!
Ah!
I'm sorry.
What just happened?
Bradley, what's going on?
I doomed him.
I...
I'm worried I picked up the knife!
I'm scared.
What is?
Something's moving in the shadows.
Oh, Charles!
Probably just a rat.
Rats.
My relationship with...
Are you fixing...
My relationship with Julia went up!
But she...
She was really...
Oh!
Oh my god!
They split me and Brad!
Brad and I got split off!
Wait, how did...
Wait, you split up?
You're by yourself now?
Yeah!
Yeah, I'm by myself!
The door...
The door closed on us!
Uh oh.
It's okay.
Oh my god!
Wait!
I'm in the room with the dead bodies!
Uh oh.
Which dead bodies?
Which...
Uh oh.
Which dead bodies?
The...
The ones that were carried on the ship at the beginning!
Oh my god!
I'm going crazy!
Brad!
I couldn't pick any other options.
I'm seeing hallucinations!
Uh oh.
Oh my god!
I'm with the bodies!
I'm with the dead bodies!
Oh!
I can look at the...
I can observe every single body!
Oh god!
I'm scared!
We're both fucking up!
Man!
We're supposed to see that!
We're both messing up!
There's two bodies in here!
There's two bodies!
What the?
What's this?
Practically falling off.
Anyway, what does that mean?
Oh, that's a bullet!
Um, is this even human?
What is this?
What is going on?
I just want to reunite with at least somebody!
I don't want to...
Oh fuck!
Leave, leave, leave!
Hold on, I'm not done yet!
I'm not done yet!
Oh!
There's zombies!
Are you okay?
What's going on?
I'm not!
You found a secret!
Oh my god!
There's zombies!
I'm just looking at the bodies!
I don't...
I found another secret!
Save Brad!
Save him!
I got another secret.
Plus four for life!
What do you mean?
You're getting secrets!
I'm...
Woo!
What do you mean?
Oh my god!
There's something over here.
Uh oh.
Something's gonna be behind here.
Oh my god!
There might be...
Brad might be dead.
What?
Brad!
Wait, it's not letting me do it now.
Oh no!
I'm in the ballroom!
Hold on.
I remember what happens on Ghost Ship!
Not the ballroom!
It's okay.
That was outside.
Wait, it's not letting me do it.
What do you mean?
That was inside the ballroom!
I saw the movie!
It's the...
No, they were out on the deck!
They were out on the deck!
Ballroom!
Wait!
The ballroom's on a deck.
Uh oh.
That might be stuck.
What are you...
What are you doing?
I'm trying to use...
I'm trying to do this.
I'm trying to do this, but it's not letting me.
My right stick is stuck.
I think...
Press it?
I think I'm having a doki.
I'm having a doki bird problem.
You gotta wait until I progress.
Keep holding the trigger.
I am!
It doesn't let me progress unless I hold the trigger.
Hmm.
Is it the left one maybe?
No.
You're going through my problem now.
Yeah.
Good.
Actually, wait.
I don't think it'll let me...
Wait.
I don't think it'll actually let me progress unless I do...
Oh, wait.
No, there's a room over here.
Never mind.
Okay, let's go.
Okay.
Sorry, guys.
I tried.
I really did.
All right.
Let's see.
What did you have to do?
Spin it.
It was like...
I'm trying to open up a curtain.
Oh my god.
But like...
Hold the stick I was.
I'll try one more time.
Oh, there's a pentagram book.
There's like a sorcery Satan book in the ballroom.
That's not good.
Guess we'll never know.
I read the spooky book.
Oh, you're cursing us.
I read the spooky book and there's blood here.
There's blood in the ballroom.
You are so...
I haven't seen a whole lot of bad stuff.
I haven't seen anything.
That's on you.
You literally put me in this situation.
What do you mean?
I didn't do anything.
Oh, I'm in like a really bad area.
I feel like I'm...
Oh, what the?
Oh, there's a blood fountain.
Why do I get all the bad stuff?
I think I see a corpse.
Oh, oh.
Oh my god.
Oh.
There's literally a blood fountain here.
Wait, what's going on?
I don't know.
Wait, now they're real people.
What?
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Oh, what the?
I'm touching.
Oh.
Where are you touching?
Where are you touching, Mint?
I touched it.
You touched it?
You touched the bad thing?
Oh, and you were telling me not to touch the bad thing, but you're touching the bad thing.
I was...
I just booped a guy.
Come on.
A dead body became alive.
Is that not bad enough?
I just went boop on his face.
Oh, I see another premonition.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait, what just happened?
Wait, what?
Somebody's drowning on this one.
Yeah, I found the picture.
Oh.
Okay, I think I was too slow.
I turned on the lights.
The lights are on now.
Oh, the lights are on.
Oh no!
It's the guy!
It's the guy with the hammer!
He's after me!
Oh wait.
I'm Bradley!
Bradley?
Wait, is he alive?
Bradley's alive?
Yeah!
Oh my god.
I did it!
Why am I by myself?
That's right.
I kept...
What?
I was following you.
He's like talking to it.
He's like, Fliss?
Hello?
Fliss?
Wait.
Wait, where'd you go?
I think I was following you.
Oh.
I think I'm in trouble.
Oh, there's a dead body!
Yeah, you were in trouble.
I left you there.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna touch this guy.
Don't, don't, don't jump at me.
Don't jump.
Why?
Am I taking the bullet out of it?
Ew!
You're definitely in trouble.
I left you there.
Why'd you do that?
I tried to save you.
I did quick time events.
You what?
You said you were gonna kill...
Oh shit!
I forgot!
You have to save myself!
I was scared!
I should have just left you!
No.
You know what?
I kept him alive so you had to play him.
I'm playing PT actually.
I'm following you but you have less clothes on.
I think you're trying to seduce me.
I'm watch...
I'm following.
Wait, what happened?
Fliss!
Oh, oh.
She just disappeared.
Oh, she's back.
I think Fliss is a ghost.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
That's what I saw too.
You saw yourself?
No, I knew you were a ghost.
Oh, I'm looking at the bullet again.
Oh, this time it says my name.
No, it says Alex on it!
Is Alex gonna get shot?
I think so.
Oh no.
Oh, Fliss, what does that mean?
Girl, what does that mean?
Do I open this again?
Nuke...
Oh, Metra Gold!
You found the gold.
I found the gold.
Guys, we're gonna be rich.
Don't be greedy.
Remember the hint.
I'm playing PT.
I'm playing PT real.
Now you know how I felt when I was...
Oh my god.
The guy with the gun is here now?
What's going on?
This is why I kept Bradley alive.
I can't see you in the weather, man.
This is why I kept Brad alive.
Now you have to deal with it.
The body is now...
It has textures floating.
It's like a...
What is that?
What is going on on your head?
The game is glitching a little bit, I think.
There's like...
Oh, the bullet turned into a slug and it's eating me?
Okay, okay.
Are you killing Bradley off right now?
Oh, we got slugs on us.
We got slugs on us.
Found a secret.
Oh my god.
I'm exploring.
Yippee-ki-yay.
Oh, look at all of these items.
I'm playing PT.
Look at all these items around me.
Let me read some more.
Let me...
Guys, guys.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, look at all this lore.
Okay, read it out loud.
Where's the lore?
Come on.
All right, I got a book too.
Oh my god.
The Stanford Operating Procedure for Handling Hazardous Chemicals.
Oh, are you ready for some science?
I put the book down.
What the...
This is my fourth time going through the same hallway.
There's just blood on the ground and a bullet.
Let's see.
It says...
Oh, it says, hi.
Hi.
Oh, I just saw Alex die.
Wait, what?
No, it's not really him.
I'm hallucinating.
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's good.
I guess...
Because we only wanted Brad to die.
Oh my god.
I fucked it up, but like, I'm pretty sure you can take it home.
Brad, you take Brad's demo.
You had every opportunity.
I was panicking.
Oh, oh, that was a quick time event.
My bad.
Uh oh.
Oh.
Oh, I might...
He might actually die.
Oh.
Wait.
Did you actually kill him?
I was adjusting the sound and I missed the quick time.
No, he's fine.
He's fine.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
You can't die from a hallucination.
Okay, this is...
What just happened?
I don't know.
Okay, this is bad.
What?
Uh, you guys.
No!
We're in a different hallway now.
We made it out!
I can't believe it.
You were given one quick time.
I had to do like 20 during that entire run!
You...
And you get one quick time event and you messed it up.
I was adjusting my sound.
Now it's just so loud.
It's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Just worry about yourself.
Why are you so obsessed with yourself?
I feel like something's gonna come out now.
Where do I go?
I don't even know where to go.
It's over here.
Where do I go?
I'm stuck.
It really is, because I don't know what to do right now.
Patrol vehicle.
Oh, there's the...
Is this here?
What?
Oh my god, I'm going crazy.
You found a secret, but I'm going crazy.
I mean, Bradley's been pretty crazy this whole time.
So like...
Oh, I found a wrench!
Oh my god.
Take that, take that.
We're back to the ballroom.
Yes!
Oh, that's the wrench!
I found that wrench earlier!
Wait, next to the guy that was hanging?
Yeah.
Okay, wait, what?
Next to the guy that hung himself?
Um, he was...
There was no hung person when I was there.
Are you sure?
Yeah, I'm... I'm pretty sure.
Who are you?
Are you sure?
Yeah...
That's sad.
Oh, the tiniest A button I've ever seen in my entire life.
Wait, what's going on?
Oh, there.
Press A.
Okay, I'm gonna head outside to the deck again and see if I can get out again.
Oh, press A.
Oh, please.
Oh, I think I'm trying the door.
I'm gonna go outside.
You're going outside?
Yeah, I'm going back outside.
I go outside again!
What the hell happened?
I'm outside!
The outside is real!
It's an old boat, Bradley.
Chill out.
Okay, I'm going downstairs.
Oh!
When you go outside, you... you... it makes you go back inside.
Oh, so he'll PT, PT.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm back here!
Here we go.
Oh, you cannot see the bottom.
Oh boy.
Bradley, you're gonna die.
You're gonna die, Bradley.
Ah!
What?
What's going on?
Oh, I think I'm... I'm fine, actually.
Oh!
Oh, you dropped a wrench.
No, don't drop the wrench!
We worked so hard for that!
What was the point of all of that?
Brad, is that you?
Oh, I'm seeing shadow people.
Uh-oh.
Brad, is that you?
No, wait, is that... do you see me?
Oh no!
I missed the cutscene!
I could kill Brad right now!
Wait, no, don't!
That's me!
Ben, don't you... that's me!
Don't kill him!
I'm gonna kill him.
Brad, that's me!
You're a zombie!
No, is that you?
That's me!
Don't do it!
That's literally me!
Do not!
Wait, there's multiple!
There's like five zombies here!
No!
There's nothing!
There's no listening!
Don't do anything!
I almost bashed your head in, I'm serious.
God damn it!
Wait, who were you playing as, Bliss?
I think so.
Holy shit, you almost bashed my head!
I almost killed you.
I almost did.
It's because you begged for it.
Oh my god, the guy is right behind us!
Oh shit!
You like huffed it over my head!
You're like, hmm, do I do this?
Oh, wait, are you Alex, right?
I think so.
Wait, I got pulled up.
What do you see in the water?
I don't know, I got pulled out now.
I saw a baby.
Or I'm in the plane!
Whoa!
Oh, he's a...
Oh my god!
There's a zombie!
Oh!
Kill the zombie, kill the zombie!
I punched him, I punched him!
I think Julia's gonna drown.
Wait, you're Julia.
Yeah, I know.
I did everything I was supposed to do!
Oh, no, I'm fine.
Oh, hello.
You still got me.
You seem really calm.
Okay, I have to help you now.
Wait, there's multiple of you!
What just happened?
Wait, what's going on?
It's all just black.
What do you mean?
I clearly saved your life!
I couldn't say anything!
Oh, this is the premonition!
What's going on?
Who do I save?
Do I do it?
Wait, who do I save?
I'm heroic!
What do you mean, who do you save?
If you're gonna save me, then you're gonna save me.
Wait, what?
That's literally my choice!
What are you doing?
Keep going!
Oh my god!
What?
Holy shit!
Man!
You made me kill a man!
I didn't kill a man!
Wait, was it you who died?
No!
Was?
You really made me kill a man!
You were already worried about me.
I was working on it!
I was making sure he beat, not actually kill him!
Do it!
You were the one.
You could have let go at any time.
You made me kill a person.
You could have stopped me.
I don't have any control over you.
You did the right thing.
Yeah, you did the right thing.
What the?
What the fuck?
How did he get thrown away?
I told you there's zombies!
Oh my god, it's him!
What the?
What is going on?
Oh my god.
What's going on?
Oh my god, punch him!
Punch him!
Do something!
Oh my god, run!
Are we doing anything?
Quick time event.
Who is he?
That's the guy that had the hammer, right?
That's the hammer guy?
Why does he look pruney?
Yeah.
He was in the water.
It's John Madan.
Oh my god, it's Madan!
It's the man of Madan!
Oh my god.
Hey, stop.
Don't mess up your QTE.
You can't trip on the stairs.
Fuck.
Uh oh.
Come on, Julia.
Hit it.
I'm going to get you from bonds.
Uh oh.
We killed daddy.
I hope-.
Oh my god, you did it!
Oh my god, I'm so proud of you!
Holy shit.
I'm so proud of you!
This is the most quick time event I've ever- I'm actually proud of you.
Which way do we go?
I don't know, I don't know.
Are you deciding or am I deciding?
I don't know!
Ah!
Jump, jump, jump!
Jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump!
Shit.
Let's jump.
We're correct.
Ah!
Oh, my bad.
It's okay.
Okay.
Um, maybe we sh...
Just to help me out.
Okay.
Maybe we shouldn't have jumped.
I pressed Y, but I also pressed...
Fight back or keep going.
Which one?
Keep going!
Fight on!
I zipped my back!
Oh!
Oh, okay!
That's fine.
You're gonna kill a second man.
You're obsessed with it.
Oh, my God!
I did it!
I'm a hero!
Bulk.
Oh, my God.
Keep going.
Oh, we're outside.
Oh, my God.
Bulk!
Oh, my God!
I'm a hero!
You're killing him!
Oh, my God!
I'm blood fursie!
This is a Maison.
This is a prison!
What are we doing?
How do you save him?
Oh, my God.
It's Fleece.
Yeah, it's me.
Come on.
Let's go.
Where's Bradley?
Oh, my God!
He's alive!
Are you guys okay?
Everybody's alive!
We're alive!
Oh, my God.
You're doing it!
We're doing it!
We're supposed to kill people, but somehow it's working.
Wait, but was Bradley alive?
Oh!
We're too good at the game, I think.
Oh my god.
Keep going, keep going.
Murder works?
I think... yeah.
I think we'll be alright here.
Okay.
What?
Why do you think that?
I don't trust you, Bradley.
Bradley?
Bradley, you almost killed Fliss!
I think he's just as surprised that everybody's alive.
Yeah.
That's kinda crazy.
I didn't see so many dead people.
Kinda disappointed in that.
Why do we meet?
You hadn't saw them come alive!
Apparently.
No.
Did we just leave?
Yeah, we just leave!
Yeah, just leave!
The whole ship died, right?
Yeah.
Let me help you out.
I watched Ghost Ship.
Oh boy, another hint.
Okay.
Yeah, I would do two.
Yeah, I need some help.
Yeah.
Give me a hint, man.
I don't want spoilers.
Well, then how can I put this?
There may be forces at play here that are more scientific.
Scientific?
Even some that are more political, you know?
Less supernatural.
What?
Perhaps you've started to realize...
His facial expressions!
Right?
3, 2, 5, 2, K... What the fuck does that mean?
Oh, they're all kings!
What does that mean?
What?
That doesn't help anything!
I get it.
Is this a gas?
Yeah, it's all gas.
It's not...
It's not supernatural.
It's the gas.
We're hallucinating because of the gases.
Yeah.
The more we're inside, the more we're getting hallucinations.
Gas, gas, gas.
I don't think we should go back inside.
Come on, Alex.
You're Julia.
Okay.
Alright.
What the hell was wrong with you back there?
I don't know, Mitt.
You almost bashed my head.
That's ridiculous.
What the fuck is going on with this ship?
We're seeing dead people.
I gotta be honest, it feels like there's some like...
Like evil.
Like literal evil going on down there.
Let's just stay calm and relatively sane about this, okay?
The stuff I saw...
It's like there were these old soldiers.
They were bodies.
They were dead.
But then they came alive and...
That doesn't sound that crazy right about now.
Alex wasn't the only Alex.
That's why I was confused!
That's like, what do you mean Alex wasn't the only Alex?
Um...
Wait, what are you deciding?
I wouldn't hurt you.
I'm truthful.
Oh, relationship went up!
We're fixing it!
We're fixing your mess!
No, your!
No, their prior mess.
They had a mess already.
We're just making it better, you know?
Is this a ghost ship?
Am I crazy or are we on a ghost ship?
Like ghost ships are real and this is one and we're totally on it and oh holy shit we're so totally fucked?
I was gonna say the same thing.
Yeah!
I'm not crazy!
I know we're the first people to see weird shit here.
Apparently the guards were super freaked out by something they saw in the cargo holds.
Oooh.
That said a bunch of guys tried to get out of a guard duty because they were really freaked out by something.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, there might be like bacteria on the gold that's eating our brains.
Oh yeah.
Oh, there might be bleeding bacteria.
Anyone figure out what happened to all the sailors?
Did they catch a rescue boat or something?
Oh, I mean we've seen their bodies though.
Yeah.
Shit.
So where did all the corpses come from?
They actually look like they've been scared to death.
Heart attack!
Ooh.
I am not gonna ask about the gold.
It keeps being like, ask about the gold.
I'm not gonna ask about the gold.
Why not?
It's a cursed gold!
Literally our heads was like, don't be greedy.
No, it's fine.
Oh, I'll ask about the gold.
Don't worry about you.
Don't be greedy!
I'm avoiding the gold!
I got you.
Don't worry.
You're not supposed to be greedy!
I'm kidding.
I'm just wondering.
I'm just wondering what's wrong with being greedy.
We're not going anywhere without the destroyer cap.
The loop needs it to run.
Did you grab that though?
She grabbed it.
No, one of the captains grabbed it.
Oh.
If we can find it and use it.
Oh, it's working!
That's great.
Do you think it still works?
Yeah, but where's the radio?
It was blinking.
See?
I know that means the radio is on, but where's the radio station?
Over there?
Probably over there, right?
Yeah.
Wait, let... Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, okay.
Wait, who am I?
Oh, I'm Fliss.
I'm Fliss.
Okay.
Okay, I'm Alex.
Okay, before we start, wait.
I need to pause.
I need to use the bathroom.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
Let's look at the collections and characters, everybody.
I'm Fliss.
I'm innocent.
I'm relaxed.
Oh.
All of our... Oh my god, my relationship with Alex is insane.
I just watched it go all the way down.
Um, Brad is whatever.
Julia is pretty down.
Um, Conrad.
But I'm innocent.
I'm relaxed.
I'm excited.
I'm altruistic.
I'm garbed.
I'm motivated.
Oh my god.
What secrets?
Wow.
Oh, actually we haven't even found that many, have we?
What's this?
Flight plan.
Uh-huh.
Private Miller.
Master Miller.
Our bearings.
What are these?
The kitchen knife.
Oh, these are the hints that we've gotten, I think.
Yeah, these are the hints.
Our premonitions.
Cut of your jib.
In the offing.
High and dry.
Master Miller.
Yeah, Master Miller.
Let's see.
What?
Oh, whoops.
Uh...
Oh gosh, I'm so used to playing Japanese games where there's circles to press okay.
Oh my gosh.
Brian Carter.
I'm back.
Oh, welcome back.
Alright.
What did... What are you doing?
I was looking at our secrets.
Yeah, did we get some good secrets?
Oh yeah.
Oh.
I'm surprised we're making it this far.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Honestly.
Okay.
Alright.
Um, anything else in here?
I don't think so.
I think we're supposed to go outside.
The longer we stay inside, the more we inhale the gas.
You're right.
But we're outside.
It's fine.
Yeah, that's why we gotta stay in... outside now.
Totally effed.
Oh my gosh.
We're so effed right now.
Why are you playing as Fliss and not my girlfriend?
Julia.
Yeah, I don't know.
I looked at our relationship.
Fliss' relationship with Alex is completely down.
What did you do?
What did I do?
You literally go like, Fliss go down there.
I've never been Fliss.
Fliss go down there.
What's this?
I'm gonna look at it.
I'm looking at it too.
I'm looking at it.
Oh, there's bullet holes there.
We can't use that.
We gotta go forward.
Oh yeah, he did accuse her of being in cahoots.
That's true.
Yeah, didn't you accuse me?
No, I didn't do that.
It was Alex.
You made the choices.
Oh, we're finding a way up?
Is that what we're doing?
We have to find a way to get up.
We have to get to the radio tower.
Oh, I thought... okay.
I thought we had to just get over there.
Oh my gosh.
We're acting really casual for like, you know, some...
For like, you know...
For almost... for seeing...
several dead people.
And I killed a man.
I killed several men.
I found a way up.
I think this is our way up.
I mean, it's the only way up.
What?
Give you a...
Yeah, you're a strong, powerful woman.
Oh my god!
Damn!
Shouldn't it be me?
That gets to lift up?
Are you right?
Holy shit!
And he doesn't even help her get all the way up.
Yeah, he just pulls you a little bit.
I was like, alright.
I did my job.
I'm a gentleman.
Dang, she's strong.
Oh, we're back.
Did no one help Brad?
No, there is a stander right there.
I know, I know, but no one helped him get up.
He just climbed up himself.
Brad, are you okay?
Oh yeah, I have to go talk to him.
You help him.
Come here, Brad.
You're gonna talk to him?
Bro, we gotta find the radio tower!
The longer we're here, the more we're inhaling the gas!
He doesn't care!
Okay, he really doesn't care about me.
He doesn't care about you.
You literally almost bashed your head.
Well, he almost bashed my head.
If anything, I shouldn't be wanting to talk to him.
Okay, we gotta split up maybe.
We gotta split up.
No, we're not splitting up.
Who's that down there?
Who's that?
There's someone down there.
No, no, no.
Over here.
Wait, there is.
Wait, you're right.
Who's that?
I'm going the other way.
I told you this way was the better way.
I told you, I told you.
Oh.
Ladies first.
You have the flashlight.
I'm a gentleman.
Alright, I'll go here.
Alright.
Alright, Madame.
No, I can't see.
It's so dark.
Madame.
Madame, why don't you just call...
It's so dark.
I can't see.
Don't worry, I'll flash... I'm holding the flashlight in front of you now.
While you...
I'm flashing your butt.
It's on the wall.
Oh my god.
What is going on here?
Oh, I don't like that camera.
I don't either.
We can't see what's in front of us.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's gone.
It's gone.
It's gone?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's gone.
Oh, it's Julia.
It's Julia.
Why were you so afraid of your own girlfriend?
No, I just wanted you to go first.
Because I'm ladies first, you know?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I guess I'll do it myself.
Yeah, do it yourself.
Dude, what was that?
Why were you screaming at my girlfriend?
I mean, it's Julia.
I thought we wanted to keep Julia alive.
Yeah, but I still don't like her.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're trapped in there.
Okay, we're trapped in the toxic gas again.
Yeah, great thinking, Alex.
Good job.
Oh, there's a guy in here.
There's a dead body.
Oh, this has to be the radio tower, right?
No, this is the captain's room, right?
Oh, this is the captain's room.
There's Brad.
Hi, Brad.
Oh, premonition.
Yeah.
We need to know the premonition.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god!
Oh!
What is it?
It was one of the bad guys.
He just shoots himself.
Oh, what?
We have to convince him to shoot himself then.
Yeah.
I'm taking in these gases.
There's a door to our right.
Yeah, there's a door over here.
Oh, what the fuck?
Bradley, are you okay?
Why are you like...
I don't think Bradley's okay.
I'm gonna walk over and they're gonna be T-posing.
Can you open that door?
No, okay.
I guess we'll go this way then.
Yeah.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh my god!
Julia, please!
Julia, what the fuck?
Why are you so chill?
Why are you just like standing there like that?
I know!
She's chill like that.
She's so chill?
Is that another premonition?
No, it's their route.
They went from California...
to home.
They went to the United States and then...
Korea?
Whoa!
It's almost like they didn't want anyone to know they were coming.
This is such a messed up... That is a long route.
In general.
Why does it go all the way down there?
There's two islands there.
Oh, I got a secret.
We got a secret.
I found a note.
Oh, I see you.
I'm watching you.
Pick it up.
Let's see.
The United States Department of the Navy.
The ship was blown off course.
The flight was bad.
They couldn't establish a position.
Oh!
There was a storm.
Well, and somebody...
went overboard.
Someone failed their...
QuickTime events.
That could have been you, Mint.
That could have been me.
Oh, there's a dead guy here.
There's dead guys everywhere.
The radio!
Wait, this is the radio!
Here.
I found it.
There's only one way.
This thing actually still works?
Yeah, I found it.
Alright, let's see if you know how to do it.
You found it!
Oh!
Good ol' short-wave radio.
What am I listening for?
Come on, fuck it.
You're the captain!
Number station?
Military bandwidth.
Which one are we trying to find?
Oh, the military.
Yeah.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Do you read us?
Over.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
That guy doesn't... I don't think that's real.
At least there's someone listening.
The signal's in and out though.
That guy is too panicked.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking too.
I'm gonna say our coordinates.
If you can hear me, we're on board an abandoned freighter.
12 degrees, 30 minutes south.
Just like when it's 911, say your address first.
251 degrees, 20 minutes west.
Over.
Please repeat.
Why is he panicking?
Yeah, I...
Mayday, mayday.
Thank you, sir.
We're on a large freighter.
Say the address.
Why are you describing it?
Coordinates.
Over.
Coordinates, coordinates.
Coordinates.
Come in, over.
Come in, come in, please, anyone.
You screwed it up.
Oh no!
Fliss, you ruined it.
You're Fliss!
No!
Come here, look!
Oh no.
Brad wants to go down.
Look at this.
Bradley's awfully brave, isn't he?
Just push him in.
Push him in.
It'll be so funny.
Yeah.
No shit.
Anywhere will lead somewhere.
I think someone should wait here in case a message comes through.
I'll go, obviously.
I can do this.
Brad, you're a hero!
Let Brad go!
Sounds like you're scared of someone stepping out of your shadow.
Brad, you almost...
You almost killed somebody!
We should have left him to die.
Try...
I...
Okay.
If you're sure you're up for it...
If he dies, he dies.
Julia, what?
You know my bodyguard.
I can take care of myself.
What?
Why are you going?
Um...
Fliss and Brad again?
Julia says she can handle it.
You're playing it for him!
You fucking...
Oh my god!
You gotta let Julia and Brad!
One of us is playing Julia and Brad.
Brad, the other...
Oh my god.
Don't say that you're gonna do it if you're not gonna do it.
Don't say it!
I hope you get Julia and Brad.
Oh my god.
So loud.
I hope you get Julia and Brad.
Oh, I'm Julia!
Julia, I'm Brad!
Julia definitely has tetanus.
She's all scraped up.
Oh no.
Everything still work?
Everyone okay?
Decide.
Are we okay?
We're okay.
Oh god, you're the crazier one.
You're gonna try and kill me at some point.
Now you'll know how I fell.
We have to find the generator.
We can power up the radio.
Okay.
We'll wait here by the radio.
Finally somebody's gonna die now.
Someone will die.
Thanks for the tiny lighter.
To set you on fire.
Let's go.
I'm gonna put a lighter up.
With toxic gas around it.
I know, right?
It just doesn't feel like a very good idea.
Are you okay?
There you go.
We look like real Scooby Doo guys.
Yeah.
Is that the sickbay?
Is that what that said over there?
We need to find the generator.
Don't split up guys.
It's probably really nasty in here.
Really gassy in here.
That's where all the dirtiest of germs are.
There's a door here.
Inhale the gases guys.
Sniffle, sniffle.
Yeah, I love going crazy.
More hallucinations.
Uh...
Wait, wait, wait.
Medical officers report minutes of meeting between scientist X, CWO Walter Bishop and CWO Tom Palmer with Sergeant Peter.
Peter Wood observing and...
Blalala...
X for meeting with our team and says we can mutually learn.
Oh!
Oh, my thing talks about Charles and Joe.
It talks about like Charles beating up Joe.
Oh!
My thing talks about Manchurian...
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, this is actually really important.
The United States has been aware of certain agencies investigating the...
chemical and biological agents in warfare.
Our act...
limited by the Geneva Protocol...
have experiments.
We are unable to...
describe...
describes an investigation during...
to test the effects of human subjects...
on the molecule crystal structure hallucinogens...
Oh!
Manchurian gold!
Oh, my God, that is!
Unitions battle.
It was... even relatively minor.
observed to trigger significant...
hallucinations.
Men... highly convincing.
Men.
Things that were not really there.
Even the danger was manifold.
And its intensity.
Okay, so it is toxic gas that we're inhaling...
right now.
What else was over here?
It was nothing.
It was just...
Lock me in jail, bad boy.
You have a boyfriend.
What the fuck.
I'm unhappy in my relationship.
I can tell.
I can tell you've been...
actively sabotaging it.
Oh, this is the report.
Oh, this is where I was at!
Yeah, you're right!
This is the Charles and Jo beating up thing.
Yeah, this is the thing I read.
And then there should be blood on the wall here.
I can't believe you tried to NTR with his brother!
That's fucked up.
Yeah, there's the blood that I saw earlier.
Oh my gosh.
Don't worry about it.
Guys, the longer we stay here, the more toxic gas we're gonna get.
Oooh!
Yummy!
I can't wait to see the kids.
How did you...
That's me.
Woah!
Did you hear that?
Oh, that's a body!
That's a dead body I found!
That's him!
What?
What's this?
No, there's a dead body literally right next to me.
Let's see.
I don't see a body.
What?
There's literally no body here.
Wait, what?
Oh, on the ground!
Yeah, I was like, what do you mean?
I'm looking at him.
What is this?
Is this important?
I observed signs of severe distress consistent with evidence of panic observed in the same soldier during his watch duty.
Oh, it's talking about the hallucination that he's been getting.
Yeah!
Oooh!
Menchurian gold, menchurian gold.
Yeah, this is the body.
This dead body.
Yeah, I didn't see him.
I thought he went in the bed.
Because that's where sick bodies normally would be.
Yeah, he was stuffed in the...
in this closet locker.
And I like...
That's why I was like...
Yeah, like a hundred years ago.
Wait, where did you go?
Oh, there you are.
I was like, where are we?
Are we splitting up already?
Yeah, we're splitting up.
We gotta get that generator.
Oh, come on.
I'm stuck.
Wait, hold on.
We can go down.
We can only go down.
Go down.
Ladies first.
Nope, I think Bradley's the latest.
Okay, touche.
Here, come check this out.
Yeah, I found the ladder.
Oh, sure, yeah.
Wait, what are you looking at?
Is this the generator?
Gotta find the kitchen raggy.
Well, it sure looks gassy in here.
Roll.
Uh oh.
Ow.
Come down here.
Come down here, Julia.
She won't be able to get back up if you tell her to come down.
Come down.
You have shoes.
I have bare feet.
I'm just a lady.
Oh, God.
What's up?
Wait, I didn't see anything.
I just heard it.
Me too.
I just heard it too.
I was not paying attention.
I don't think there was something there.
You're not.
Okay, so, follow my thinking here.
Okay.
We know this ship was carrying the Venturi and gold.
Yeah.
But that was really some sort of hallucinogenic bioweapon developed in China during World War II.
Right.
And we know that it was super unstable.
Yeah.
So maybe it's still here?
Maybe it has a secret.
Wait, but why am I...
Oh!
Oh my God, Brad!
You're so smart!
It's not like we figured that out a long time ago.
He's the...
He's the brainy nerd.
We might die because the military wants to keep it a secret.
Yeah.
Oooh!
Maybe in the end only Conrad survives.
No, I'm kidding.
Nobody here lives.
Because that's usually how it goes.
The military wants to keep it a secret.
So then we're going to be like...
Well, we know those coordinates.
Yeah, they'll be like...
We'll be like, we're saved!
And then the military shoots us.
That's how it always goes.
Yep.
Oh, Netherlands.
Netherlands?
Oh, Rotterdam.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
This is not an American ship.
No.
Oh my God.
It's not American at all.
It's not made in America.
They lied to us.
How dare they?
You go the other way.
No, we're not splitting up.
Yeah, why not?
I can't believe we outsourced this ship to Europeans.
That's why it's cursed.
That's...
I don't think there's anything over here except gas.
What are you trying to say about...
Hop it up!
Hop up the gas!
My delusions!
Oh my God, anime girls!
Anime girls are real!
We're gonna see the children!
It's this way.
There's stuff here.
I'm seeing anime girls.
Oh my God.
Hop up the gas!
Oh, what's this?
Wait, did we come this way?
No, we didn't.
We came from upstairs.
Oh, you're right.
How?
How do we go back upstairs?
Boom!
Sure.
Oh!
Yay!
Baby!
Over!
We need help now!
There are things on the ship that are trying to hurt us!
Over!
Recovery mission is on route to your location.
Over.
Oh!
Again?
Come on, work diamond!
Okay.
Okay, well, now... We have people coming to shoot us!
Yeah, we have people coming to shoot us!
Oh my God!
We did it!
There's a way over here, but there was also another...
area... all the way on the other side.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
Oh, gas!
Sweet, sweet gas!
My waifu will... she will be mine!
My God!
This is how your waifu's become 3D!
No 3DPD!
We won't... Oh, there's a dead guy here!
Wait, where are you?
I'm looking at a dead guy.
Where did you go?
He is not looking so hot.
Where the fuck did you go?
Did you go this way?
Oh, we definitely split up.
Oh, we...
Wait, what?
I brought you back!
Wait, they were here?
I feel like we should.
Might as well.
Yeah, take it.
Yeah, why not?
Yeah.
The crows!
Uh oh.
Oh no.
Just when we need to run.
Wait, we can hit him over the head with it!
You're right!
Is this where he's gonna shoot himself?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh.
Oh, he's dead!
He's totally lost it.
Yeah, he's crazy.
Uh oh.
Oh, you see it?
Ahhh.
Wow, imagine the smell in there.
What is he doing?
That's the guy... Oh!
There's the...
Oh, there's the thing!
Yeah, for the bowl!
What is he trying to do?
Is he gonna cut him?
He's opening...
He's gonna open him up to see his secrets.
There's gold inside him.
Open him up.
Open me up!
There's gold inside!
Oh, he's hallucinating.
He's hallucinating again.
You could totally like scare him.
Just be like...
I see you.
Okay, okay.
Don't you dare.
Don't you dare fuck this up.
Okay.
We die, you messed us up.
There's a lot of pressure here, though.
There's a lot of...
The stress makes it...
There's a lot of pressure.
There you go.
See?
I told you.
There's a lot of pressure.
You failed?
No, I didn't.
I didn't fail?
You failed.
It sounds like you failed.
Avoid Olsen.
Uh-oh.
What are we supposed to do?
I don't know.
I have time to read notes, right?
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
There's mucho texto.
Wait, what?
Human bodies that have undergone this treatment.
I don't think we have time to read!
Okay, I'm coming.
What's going on?
Oh!
Oh, what's going on?
Oh god!
Hide!
We've got to split.
We've got to split!
He's holding something.
I'm just gonna check it real quick.
There's nothing in there!
I swear to...
I swear to god.
I was just curious.
Now we're gonna die.
This guy can only...
He can only...
He can only hallucinate and...
There must be plenty of that to go around.
He'll hallucinate us killing us.
It's fine.
Where are we gonna go anyway?
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh god.
And I'm to be left here.
To die.
But I am...
Mitt!
I swear to god!
I knew I shouldn't have given you the pressure!
If I kept giving you pressure, it would've been okay!
It was the only key to success!
Let's just kill him!
It was all the pressure!
The whole thing I stopped giving you pressure!
See?
It's fine.
Oh.
Keep going!
Just keep...
Bradley, please.
The doors are rusted.
Come on, we gotta keep going.
AHHHH!
Okay.
This is where he tries to shoot...
We have to convince him to shoot himself.
Yeah, this is the guy that I saw shoot himself.
Turn around.
Oh.
Slow.
Very slow.
Then we'll get a gun.
It'll be fine.
Yeah, real slow.
Okay.
Why is he here?
How did he get here?
Slow.
Yeah, why is he here?
How did he get here?
What do you mean?
Oh.
Mint, I swear to god.
I saw you!
I'm not...
You're not a spirit!
We just wanna get out of here.
Please.
I'm sorry, but...
If you're breathing, then you don't get much of a choice in the matter.
You don't got a say.
What do you mean?
Oh, he's seeing him.
It's all gone changing on me!
Whoa, the gas.
What's changing?
The gas.
Stay away!
Stay back from the mist!
Wait, what's happening?
There's a man!
Don't breathe the mist!
The man, I'm a dead!
Oh my god, I saw him too!
Don't breathe the mist.
The mist, the mist!
Oh, I'm gonna say nothing.
Really?
I'm gonna say nothing.
You coward, you coward!
Inside with us.
Now.
Please just calm down.
Why'd you say something?
I didn't!
Why did I make the decision?
It's in one of us.
Isn't it?
We have to convince this on him.
It's in him.
We have to say it's in him.
Oh yeah, I'll say I haven't breathed any weird mist.
Please, I promise.
My deceitful went up.
Oh, me too.
I'm gonna say no.
It's happening.
You breathe it.
Yeah, Bradley, you breathe it.
No!
He's gonna shoot Brad!
Shoot Brad, shoot Brad.
There is no...
There was something back...
Oh, what did I do?
There is no mist!
There was something back there!
Hey, alright, look.
I think he's gonna shoot Brad.
I fucked up.
Uh oh, he's gonna shoot Brad.
I messed up!
I knew it.
I told you.
Alright, we won it.
Did you breathe it in?
No.
Say no.
We held our breath.
No, look.
We did not breathe any of that stuff.
I fucked up.
I fucked up!
Brad's gonna die!
We've been down here for hours.
You've been holding your breath this whole time.
It's true.
You're holding your breath right now.
Uh oh.
Oh, we did it!
We did it!
How did...
I can feel it swelling out of me now.
What if he shoots us first?
He's judging me!
Okay.
Come on, man.
Come on, shoot yourself.
The mist!
Persona!
What do we do?
Brad, Pistola, distract!
You decide!
Stop!
Stop lying!
You can all see it in me, can't you?
Persona, did you say...
Come on, come on.
I didn't say anything!
Why are you making him stall?
Oh, oh, oh.
You're keeping me alive!
Dude just can't stop monologuing.
Oh, there it is!
Oh, maybe, maybe.
Persona?
Hey, man, come on.
Just quit.
Oh!
Oh, fucking shit.
We did it!
Let's go!
We killed another man!
Yeah, we killed another man!
There's the option!
Yeah!
Wait, why don't you keep the gun?
Is it empty?
Someone was like, you could have saved him.
Wait, we're supposed to save him?
Oh.
No, it was our premonition!
It was our premonition!
I thought we were supposed to kill him!
We were...
That was our mission!
Oh, I'm bliss.
Oh, it's 444!
Yeah, how sweet.
Oh, don't...
Oh my god, it's so spooky!
Yeah, they took us hostage!
Why are we supposed to save... He's the bad guy!
Yeah!
Doesn't sound like my problem!
There might be some more gear down there we can use.
Murderers of my dad!
We were the murderers all along!
Oh my god.
Oh, they're going down.
Okay.
Why are we saving the kidnappers?
Oh my god!
I swear to god.
I don't think...
No, I'm bliss.
I'm bliss.
Okay.
I'm doing this then.
Are you doing it right now?
Yes, I am.
Mess up.
Hey.
I had a good track record with this!
It's on you!
How did you mess this up?
It's too much pressure!
The poor kid!
The moment I give you pressure, you do better!
I don't understand how that works with you!
When I stress you out, you actually pass this!
Oh my god, there's a man down there!
The man of a dad!
The murderers of my dad.
Let's go.
Why can't I walk fast?
I don't know.
Come on, move, Bliss.
Move.
Move you!
I'm trying!
She's so slow!
Every time I pass it, it says, Mint failed it.
Even though you don't do it.
Even the game says you failed it.
It calls me out!
You disappeared!
I'm here!
I'm heading over!
I'm slowly heading over!
Oh my god.
Oh, he's coming over!
It doesn't matter.
We need that distributor cat.
Stop talking!
Stop!
He's so loud, Alex!
I know!
He's like, hey, it's over here!
Hey, it's here!
This is not the way that we win.
How are they gonna find us?
Oh, is that your hand?
I don't know.
I sure hope so.
I sure hope so, too.
Oh, uh oh.
Wait, I don't think I can go this way.
How is there still more?
Who's that?
Oh!
Oh, he sees us!
What?
Jump.
Are we actually gonna do it?
This is a lot deeper than I expected.
Yeah, it's pretty uh... uh... Get ready for the quick time!
What's the first one?
Min, please.
Oh, wait!
I don't think I had to do it!
The gases!
Oh no, the gases!
The gases are like really...
He dropped the hammer!
What is it zooming on?
The hammer!
We'll get it.
We'll grab that.
I swear, do not use the hammer against me!
Oh, is he getting heart attack?
Oh, he's gonna get scared to death!
He's getting scared to death now!
I think we have to do this fast.
But we're gonna get heart...
Okay, this is... Yeah.
This is the moment.
Are you fucking kidding me?!
I have to get a fucking...
Oh my god!
I have to make sure I don't get a heart attack!
My chicken down!
Let's go!
Are you fucking... Alright, I gotta make sure I don't get a heart attack, I guess.
Oh, I'm outside.
Breathing that fresh air.
I can't believe it!
This is actual bullshit.
Oh, yeah.
I'm fucking going as fast as I can!
I'm going too!
I'm pressing LB!
LB!
Is this it here?
Oh, I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
I'm going to the door.
It's fine.
Wait, who's that?
What's that down there?
Oh my god.
Hold on, I'm coming!
Hold on.
I think those are bodies.
Wait, that's a guy right there.
Oh!
Of course, but they will shrink your movement.
Notaries indicate that M5's platoons have gone missing.
What?
I'm coming.
Hold on.
Is there any... Oh, there's a lot of stuff in here.
I'm breathing in the gas.
There's a lot of stuff in here.
Hold on.
I'm trying to figure it out where he is.
He's dead!
It's fine!
Oh no.
The rats!
Water purification!
There's rats eating the dead body!
Why did you get to go outside?
I'm reading.
I'm exploring.
It's kinda nice.
Oh my god.
I saw a dead body.
He was just chilling though.
Manifest a personal effects.
Oh no.
The dog died.
Oh, these are the guys that died.
Oh.
Oops.
Get off!
Get off rat!
I'm fine.
Hold on.
There's like three notes in here.
Get off!
Oh my god.
Uh oh.
I didn't get to read it!
Why do I have to deal with all of this?
There's rats here!
Wait, I just heard something.
Oh my god.
There's so many rats.
I'm freaking out.
I'm freaking out over the rats.
Oh, I see you freaking out over the rats.
Chill out!
What the hell?
What the fuck was that?
What's going on?
Do I...
Um, decide well I guess.
What?
Who are you?
That's me!
Don't do anything!
Yeah, it's me, idiot!
It's me!
Is that you?
That's me!
Don't do anything!
It's me!
Uh oh.
I think Bliss might die.
You're the one who's gonna kill.
The game is bugging out, man.
What?
I'm dying?
Why are you dying?
What's going on?
The rats!
There are no rats!
Don't kill me!
Don't you dare!
Don't you dare, man!
Don't kill me!
I'm gonna put you out of your misery, Alex.
Don't you fucking kill me!
I'm gonna put you out of your misery!
Don't do anything to me!
Stop!
There were no rats!
The whole time!
Oh my god.
The game is bugging out right now.
It's always you that's about to kill me!
I swear to god!
I know you were the one with the knife!
I didn't do anything with the knife!
You were a monster on my screen!
You were a monster!
What are you talking about?
You had two heads!
Well, you looked like you were getting eaten by rats, but you weren't actually.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck did he come from?
Why are you there?
Wait, Brad.
No way.
Did we survive?
Did we save everybody?
Did we?
Did we die?
Oh my god.
Did we?
What the fuck?
No way.
There's no way.
There's no way we saved everybody.
Oh my god.
Let's try it.
Even Conrad.
That's actually crazy.
Holy shit.
Are we just gonna forget that everything happened?
We're just gonna leave this ship and just forget anything ever happened?
What about Conrad?
I thought Conrad was gonna come back.
I know.
I thought so too.
That fucking bastard.
He just dipped.
Oh my god.
No way.
That actually worked.
Oh, there he is!
There he is!
There's Conrad!
No way.
He came back.
He has a gun.
Wait.
No way.
He's gonna get on the ship.
Doki, wait.
No, he doesn't know.
They're gonna kill Conrad at the end.
Conrad, no!
Oh, no.
Holy shit.
Oh, my god.
No, Conrad, don't go on.
No, don't go back.
Where's the rest of the Coastal Guard?
Where is it?
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's inviting him in.
Yeah.
Oh, there he goes.
Oh, no.
There he goes in.
Oh, my god.
Conrad!
No!
Conrad, no!
Don't be greedy.
Do we get a choice?
No.
Just let him die.
No way.
We saved him.
Just for him to go back to the ship.
He has his airpods on!
Where is the Coastal Guard?
He's not on the ship.
How did he get in here?
Oh, my god.
I can't believe it.
This is as cool as Man of Conrad.
I don't know what happened to my brother.
He was trying to help us to get help, but...
He doesn't know anything about what's going on.
Oh, it's like the Until Dawn ending.
Yeah.
Where they do the interviews and stuff.
God, we should have never split up.
Oh.
That's just her being sad about Conrad.
That's it.
We don't know if he's dead or not.
He's just chilling.
Oh, my god.
No way.
That's the ending.
No fucking way.
We're like, where's Conrad?
Technically, we saved everybody.
No way.
That's the ending.
Oh, my god.
What is he going to say?
Is he just going to stare at us?
Did we make good choices?
Congratulations.
Your charges are still breathing.
That's something.
That's really impressive for us.
Yeah, that really is.
I can't believe we were not trying to save people.
It's all about decisions, isn't it?
Decisions made in a hurry.
In a panic.
Made with the heart instead of the head.
Or vice versa.
Sometimes those decisions take a long time.
Truly, Conrad.
But there are repercussions.
There are?
Yeah, Conrad's dead now.
We don't know that.
There's no proof.
I think so.
I think he's dead.
Did we get the good ending?
The boat literally invited him in.
Maybe in Little Hope.
Maybe somewhere else.
Whoa.
But be certain.
I'm sure we'll meet again.
Whoa.
It's inevitable.
Apparently there's a DLC.
I don't know if that guy was baiting us.
What the fuck?
Are we skipping?
Yeah, skip to the end.
There's DLC?
For real?
Is there really a DLC?
Oh, that was a joke.
Okay.
Are they vibrating for you?
What's going on?
Are we getting a heart attack?
They're vibrating?
Whoa.
What's going on?
Is it because of the beer?
The decompression?
Is this the decompression?
Oh my god!
It's the beer!
I'm shaking a lot.
Shit!
This is decompression sickness.
I swear to god!
You killed her in the end because of the decompression!
Why are they vibrating?
Oh my god!
Yeah!
We almost saved everybody!
She said congratulations.
We went through the credits.
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
It was beer o'clock!
Please!
Beer o'clock!
Fucking beer o'clock!
We almost had a perfect run!
Beer o'clock!
I can't!
Oh my god!
Fucking beer o'clock!
Yeah, it was after the credits so it doesn't count.
Guys, it doesn't count!
It doesn't count, guys!
It was after the credits!
It doesn't count!
What happens after the credits is not our fault!
Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
She died from beer o'clock!
After everything we've been through!
Fucking beer o'clock got us!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
You know, I'm surprised everybody lived.
That was actually...
I'm surprised too!
Oh my god!
That's right!
We're special!
No other VTuber plays the game like us!
We stumbled our way into victory!
You can guarantee an original experience here on our channel!
Beers of Medan!
I can't believe beer o'clock!
Why did the decompression take so long?
He said it was like a couple hours or maybe a couple minutes.
Michael!
How did he die?
How did she die now?
Oh my god!
That was good.
Did you like it, man?
That was fun!
That was really fun.
We should do the sequel to this next time.
Is the sequel the same where we have to play two different characters?
I think so, yeah.
I heard Little Hope's not as good though.
Oh yeah.
I think all of these are all kind of like, kuso games.
Yeah.
It's not the game, you guys.
It's who plays the game.
Yeah, it's who plays the game, guys.
Oh my god.
At least, hey, nobody died, okay?
Anything that happens, it's a game.
Anything that happens after the credits is not like our fault.
Yes, yes.
Anything that happens is not our fault.
Yeah, but it might not be B-Roll Clock.
It could have been something else.
It could have been.
No one important died.
That's true.
Like, guys, Conrad's alive.
We probably saved Alex, you know?
Is Conrad alive?
Yeah, Conrad's alive, guys.
Conrad's alive.
Like how some of them are like, you were supposed to save that one kid next to us.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, he kidnapped us.
He kidnapped us!
He's a pirate!
Yeah, self-defense!
Yeah, it was either us or him.
Yeah.
Someone was like, it's a hallucination, she's alive.
She's still on the trip, on the ship.
She's like, Conrad!
I waited for you!
Someone was like, time of death, B-Roll Clock.
Oh my god, I didn't think that that would be...
You didn't think actions had consequences?
No.
After the doctor boyfriend was like, maybe you shouldn't drink the beer.
People are saying, don't do Little Hope that it's actually bad.
Oh, is it actually bad?
Wait, how many games are in the anthology?
Anyway.
Is House of Ashes apparently...
Is House of Ashes good?
Conrad survived up to the credits, therefore it doesn't matter.
So true!
So true.
I went very hard on those QuickTime events.
House of Ashes is good.
Okay, we'll do House of Ashes next.
Yeah, that was really fun.
How bad are we saying though?
Like, in what way is it bad?
Like, I mean...
Bad as in like the story bad?
Or is it like the...
Is it like buggy bad?
Yeah.
If it's buggy bad, then maybe not.
But if it's story bad, we can make it work.
I thought this one was great.
Yeah, this one was good.
This one was pretty good.
The story is terrible?
Oh, okay.
Then that's perfect for us.
Yeah!
I was trying to be a Mercier and then Min here was reading a diary in a British accent.
While we watched somebody get killed on screen.
It's like, dear diary.
And then my own voice was like, ahhhh!
You know, whatever.
Yeah, we'll fix it.
We can fix the story.
Don't worry.
And if the story is boring, we'll just make a podcast.
Open the Swift ending game.
It's not the game.
It's who plays it.
Yeah, it's who plays it.
Exactly.
What a great time.
We gotta continue the trilogy.
Yeah, we gotta continue the anthology.
The Dark Pictures.
Yeah, we have to continue the Dark Pictures anthology.
Oh, crap.
Well, thank you!
Yeah, thanks man.
I can't believe everybody lived.
Other than beer o'clock, I can't believe it.
I thought maybe she would die on the ship.
Yeah.
Like, oh my god, it's kicking in.
It's decompression.
Yeah, but no.
And that one decision you made.
She just collapses on the boat.
She died of cringe.
Oh man.
Oh my god, it just came out of nowhere too.
We were just like, yay, we did it.
Also, we weren't intentionally trying to save them.
We were just...
We just stumbled upon it.
Yeah.
We just tripped and fell into saving everybody somehow.
Yeah, somehow...
I mean, we did all the QTE.
Well, I failed the one QTE.
The heartbeat one.
We still lived.
One?
Whatever.
The one important one.
The one at the end.
Okay.
I see we're rewriting history right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the one.
I see you're not even paying attention to beer o'clock.
The most important one.
Beer o 'clock wouldn't have happened if...
I don't know.
You exploded the grill.
I literally just...
Don't do it.
Do not drink the beer.
It was...
It was just beer o'clock.
The doctor boyfriend was being like, that's a bad idea.
It was fun.
It was fine.
We didn't care about Julia anyway.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah, she was...
She was...
Yeah, she was pretty much a Karen, to be fair.
She was.
Yeah.
So it's like, you know, nothing...
You know, he told...
Alex could have got...
He could have gotten a job so much better, you know?
Yeah.
And then Alex...
Yeah, we saved him from the marriage.
Now Alex is gonna fall in love with Flix.
Or Flix.
Yeah, Fliss.
Fliss.
Yeah.
Fliss, yeah.
Yeah, Fliss is so much better.
Yeah, Fliss almost got together with Conrad.
Oh my God.
They were making out.
Yeah, yeah.
And then we saved them.
We got...
We got Fliss for Alex now.
She's a strong woman.
I can't believe Conrad just literally like front of the boat, like...
Yeah, we're...
We're just...
What if Fliss is the coast guard?
I don't know.
Like he just went there by himself.
He was clearly not driving the boat.
No.
Yeah, so it makes this...
Why is he dealing with this?
Yeah, it's like where did...
Where did the...
Where did the coast guard go?
I...
Also, how did he get the coordinates?
I was like, yeah.
Why...
Why did he get the coordinates?
Well, we gave the coordinates over the...
Over the radio...
Yeah.
But how did he know to go with...
Like...
How...
What?
Yeah, but then like the thing is...
He...
They were...
They were on the...
Oh, my gosh.
They weren't on the military boat.
They weren't on the...
Yeah, exactly!
Everybody else was also on the military boat.
Yeah!
So like... I'm so confused.
Why was there nobody behind?
Oh my god...
It's alright.
Everybody lived.
Everything that happens after credits was a hallucination.
Someone said if you don't get the distributor cap, you get rescued by the Coast Guard.
Oh!
So you picked up the...
You told us... You told me to pick up the cap!
Okay, but like... If we picked up the cap, then like...
Then like... Would...
Doki killed Conrad.
Would Conrad be on the boat?
Would Conrad be on the boat and see them?
He'd be on the boat and then be like, Oh my god!
We're rescuing you guys!
Okay, I think we're getting gaslit.
I think we were supposed to get... I think we were supposed to...
Supposed to pick it up.
I don't know.
I think we're being...
We're supposed to pick it up.
I'm pretty sure.
No, because we called the Coast Guard.
They were coming.
They were on their way.
This cannot be on me.
Wait, so...
So like... If we didn't pick up the distributor cap, we would have seen Conrad on the boat?
And it would be like, Conrad!
I think so.
Yeah, they were on their way.
Someone said not picking up gives you the better ending.
How do I not pick it up?
Do I just like not do it?
Like...
I don't know what you said.
How do I not pick up the cap?
Oh, they would have ran into each other.
Guys, I gave you guys a different... I gave you guys a cooler ending, okay?
Yeah, the cooler...
Actually, the ending we got was so crazy.
Yeah, the ending we got was so much better, guys.
It was actually so much better.
Like, do you guys really want to get rescued by Conrad?
Come on.
Someone was like, you got the better ending.
Now the world is protected by... from Conrad's frizz.
We took out both of the siblings.
It's fine.
Yeah, we got a... we got a two for one special.
Great.
Anyway, thank you, Dokie.
This was a good time.
Yeah, that was a good time.
GGs, man.
We'll come back for the next... what was it?
Little Hope or House of...
Whatever one we decide to play, I guess.
Yeah, yeah, we'll come back to that.
GGs.
Alright, we're going to talk to our chats now.
Yeah.
Alright, see you, man.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Oh my god.
I'm the Peter O'Clock.
Guys, you can't be sad about losing Conrad.
It's fucking Conrad.
Don't lie to me.
You guys are not actually sad about losing Conrad.
Don't... don't... I know you guys don't actually care about him.
You guys were like, no, Dokie, why did you save Conrad?
No!
Don't pretend you cared about Conrad this entire time.
I know that's not true.
I'm trying to find our chat overlay right now.
There it is.
Yeah.
Yeehaw.
What the fuck?
Okay, yeehaw.
Oh my god.
I'm waiting for Zynga, man.
That was fun, though.
I had a lot of fun.
Um...
Let's see.
Fado, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why didn't anyone use the boat radio to contact the Coast Guard and tell them that they're okay?
Okay, now they get the super chat because the radio died.
Oh, that was really, really, really fun.
I definitely had a great time playing with Mint today.
Um, I'm glad we chose Madame Adon.
It was one of the games that we were never able to actually play in the past.
So we were like, oh my god, let's play it.
Let's actually play this game now that we can.
I'm glad we did.
Um, it was... I never... I didn't expect how it was gonna go.
And so, like, everything was such a surprise.
Like, the decisions that we made.
Um...
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That was a super fun collab.
Thank you so much for the stream, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I had so much fun.
Oh, I wish I could talk to you guys more, but my throat is dying right now.
So, I'm gonna have to call it here, everybody.
Um, but like I said, it was incredibly fun.
I had a great time with Mint and I had a great time with you guys, Dragones.
And also the... the Wisp as well.
So, I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
Um, so my voice can relax a little bit.
But, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you sit up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Mmm... Bye!
I need to find the ending stream.
Haha!
Bye!